cet après-midi nous accueillons monsieur
le ministre Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et les outre-mer pour une
audition qui est consacrée vous le savez
aux violences urbaines survenues dans
notre pays à compter du 27 juin dernier
et les jours suivants des événements qui
ont donné lieu à des actes extrêmement
graves qui ont provoqué une inquiétude
au sein de la population et des élus et
je peux je pense notamment aux maires de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses qui avec sa famille a
été violemment agressée et qui a fait le
pied de menace inacceptable c'est
violence urbaine ont été de grande
ampleur et elles ont débuté après
l'annonce du décès le 27 juin à Nanterre
d'un jeune de 17 ans Naël à la suite de
l'usage d'une arme à feu par un policier
dans le cadre d'un refus d'obtempérer
alors que le jeune était au volant d'un
véhicule et peu de temps après une
diffusion de la vidéo montrant le tir du
policier sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
fait font actuellement l'objet d'une
enquête en cours et ils ont ils ont
soulevé beaucoup d'émotions et
d'interrogations ils ont conduit à la
mise en détention provisoire du policier
qui avait fait
usage de son arme
le bilan des violons urbaines qui a
suivi et particulièrement lourd on
compte plus de 2500 bâtiments incendies
ou dégradés dont une centaine de mairies
plus de 6000 voitures brûlées plus de
700 blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre
et près de 3600 personnes plaçant de
garde à vue et vous avez pour cela
Monsieur le Ministre mobilisé un nombre
impressionnant de force de l'Europe près
de 45000 sur plusieurs jours qui ont
permis de rétablissement de l'ordre en
un temps record c'est un commentaire de
ma part je vais donner la parole d'abord
vous donner la parole pour une
introduction ensuite chaque collègue
aura deux minutes pour intervenir j'ai
moi-même deux observations d'abord moi
je voudrais que vous puissiez tirer les
conséquences du déploiement des forces
de l'ordre sur ces jours sur comment
elles l'ont été quel bilan vous en tirez
sur l'usage des vidéos qui a été fait à
cette occasion et sur la façon dont le
traitement vous appréciez le traitement
judiciaire qui en était fait je voudrais
aussi que vous puissiez revenir puisque
c'est un peu le fil rouge de notre
action sur une audition vous aviez
conduite en novembre 2020 dans
définition des lois et notamment lorsque
vous aviez décrit les sept péchés
capitaux de la police qui avait amené
une réforme importante le bobo de la
sécurité cette péché que vous décriviez
comme le manque de moyens le manque
d'encadrement le manque de formation le
fonctionnement des inspections le
recours à la vidéo la relation de la
police avec les citoyens et la relation
de la police avec la justice qui ont le
donner lieu à plusieurs interventions
avec un renforcement inégalé des moyens
c'est la locmi avec des évolutions en
cours notamment sur l'encadrement dans
la police sur l'augmentation de la durée
de formation et je voulais voir dès lors
que ces mesures sont des mesures de long
cours qui appellent à des évolutions
profondes et qui ne peuvent pas se
traduire par des changements immédiats
le bilan que vous en faites aujourd'hui
à date et ce que vous en attendez à
l'avenir monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés tout d'abord je
voudrais une fois encore saluer l'action
des élus notamment des merdes des
policiers des gendarmes des
sapeurs-pompiers des policiers bicipaux
qui durant la semaine du 27 juin au 4
juillet ont connu plusieurs nuits des
meute et d'actes de délinquance
extrêmement grave une fois de plus je
pense que tout le monde a vu qu'ils ont
démontré
le mot n'est pas trop fort qu'ils
étaient des héros du quotidien de la
République pour protéger nos concitoyens
le bien public et également les biens
privés entre le 27 juin et le 4 juillet
850 policiers gendarmes et
sapeurs-pompiers ou policier municipaux
ont été blessés parfois grèvement ce
sont eux qui ont permis à l'état de
tenir bon face au désordre et de
rétablir comme vous l'avez dit merci
monsieur le Président
l'ordre public dans un temps le plus
rapide possible
comme chacun le sait les violences que
nous avons connues ont démarré après le
drame sont venus à Nanterre vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le Président le 27 juin
dernier avec le décès d'un jeune homme
lors d'une action de de police par deux
motards de la DOPC qui dépendait de la
police de des Hauts-de-Seine des débuts
je crois que on peut constater que la
transparence a été totale sur ce drame
qui s'agisse des expressions publiques
que j'ai pu tenir au sein de la première
ministre évidemment de la justice qui
était saisie très rapidement le policier
était mis en cause mis en cause pardon a
été immédiatement entendu puis placé en
garde à vue pendant 48 heures avant
d'être mis en examen et placé en
détention provisoire l'inspection
générale de la police nationale a été
saisie par les services de la justice
d'abord par le procureur de la
République puis par des juges
d'instruction je veux évidemment dire
que la mort de ce jeune homme a suscité
parmi le nombre de nos concitoyens et
d'émotions très fortes et légitimes mais
la perte de la vie d'un homme et
singulièrement d'un adolescent 17 ans et
toujours un drame
quel lien cependant entre ce drame et
les violences très fortes qui lui ont
succédé qu'il y a entre la mort de ce
jeune homme et l'attaque de 90
établissements scolaires école dont
certaines d'entre elles ont été
totalement détruites de 103 mairies de
180 commissariats caserne de gendarmerie
brigade de sapeur-pompiers bureau de
police municipale qu'il y a entre la
mort d'un jeune homme et les menaces et
agressions physiques extrêmement fortes
parfois très grave qui ont touché 27
élus dont vous l'avez dit le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses mais il n'est pas le
seul je pensais évidemment au maire de
Charleville-Mézières à la maire de
Pontoise et bien d'autres bien
évidemment auquel nous apportons tout
notre soutien rien ne peut justifier ces
violences qui sont à la fois
destructrices et particulièrement
spectaculaire parfois
particulièrement belliqueuse vis-à-vis
des institutions et de force de sécurité
et des milliers de commerces qui ont été
pillés ou détruits
c'est sûr que ces attaques ont d'abord
principalement visé des services publics
un peu partout sur le territoire
national 11 distinction de quartier de
communes beaucoup ont été touchés qu'il
s'agit de centre urbain très important
de communes plus rurales qui ne
connaissaient jusque là pas de violence
urbaine particulièrement là où
d'habitude nous avons d'autant plus
besoin de la République
nous pouvons ici le redire et étant élu
de ses propres quartiers populaires je
sais que comme beaucoup d'entre vous
nous le savons tous les désordres les
quelques milliers de personnes
difficiles à évaluer il reviendra si
vous le souhaitez ne représente
évidemment pas l'immense majorité des
habitants des quartiers populaires des
plus jeunes d'entre eux qui veulent
vivre au sein de notre République et
pouvoir être protégé dans leur
épanouissement personnel
d'études ou professionnelle comme tous
les Français je sais qu'il condamne ces
violences et ils sont d'ailleurs les
premières victimes de ces violences ceux
qui n'ont pas pu sortir pendant
plusieurs nuits parfois de chez eux qui
ont vu leur médiathèque leurs écoles
leur mairie leur poste de police leur
commerce leur poste brûler
dès le début de cet épisode de violence
nous avons pris à la demande du
Président de la République des mesures
d'une grande fermeté qui je crois était
totalement proportionnée avec les
difficultés que nous avons connues je
veux dire d'ailleurs que tout cela s'est
fait sans recourir à aucun article de la
Constitution qui prévoyait un état
d'urgence particulier sans prendre de
mesures de restriction des libertés en
laissant l'autorité judiciaire faire son
travail
sans aucune espèce de restriction et
avec les moyens de droit commun qui sont
mis à disposition du mises intérieur et
des préfets de la République
le jour de ce drame nous attendions
évidemment quelques réactions qui
relevaient des manifestations
puisqu'elles avaient été annoncées et
donc nous nous préparions à une soirée
voire une nuit d'ordre public
c'est-à-dire de manifestations à
encadrer même spontané même entre
guillemets sauvages dont déclaré en
préfecture et nous sommes aperçus la
première nuit qu'il ne s'agissait pas de
manifestations mais d'acte de
délinquance et donc le dispositif
d'ordre public n'était pas le meilleur
pour tenir cela puisque s'attaquer à des
émeutes urbaines n'est pas tenir des
manifestations même spontanées c'est
pour cela que nous comprenons qui a une
sorte de changement de posture du
ministère de l'Intérieur entre la
première nuit où nous attendions des
manifestations aux autres nuits où nous
avons compris que l'avion à faire à des
violences
urbaines que rien ne laissait prévoir
dans ses proportions bien évidemment et
c'est pour cela que le travail que nous
avons fait était un travail en effet de
lutte contre
urbaine et ses actes de délinquance
c'est pour cela que dès le lendemain
j'ai décidé de déployer 45000 policiers
et gendarmes sur l'ensemble du
territoire national avec comme soutien
des unités d'intervention
particulièrement spécialisées que chacun
connaît le raid la Berry GIGN pour
chacun des zones de compétences des
moyens spécialisés tels que les
hélicoptères de la gendarmerie nationale
un tiers de ces hélicoptères ont volés
j'entends parfois que 100% d'entre eux
ont été utilisés ce n'est pas vrai un
tiers de ces hélicoptères envolés des
drones qui ont été utilisés évidemment
puisque vous nous les avez autorisés
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
et des véhicules blindés notamment de la
gendarmerie nationale qui ont été
autorisés par la première ministre
puisque ce dispositif est sur
proposition de business intérieur
autorisée par la première ministre la
consigne qui était donnée était aussi
d'interpellation systématique de toute
personne qui commettait des actes de
délinquance ces moyens inédits ont été
je crois à la fois dissuasif et efficace
et vous l'avez dit au bout de quatre
jours les émeutes urbaines dont certains
les ont comparé aux épisodes de 2005 qui
ont duré bien plus longtemps chacun son
rappel avec l'utilisation de l'état
d'urgence son retourner dans un calme au
début relatif puis désormais total et
chacun peut constater que deux weekends
sont passés notamment les fêtes des 13
et 14 juillet dont nous nous on
prétendait en effet qu'ils étaient ils
auraient été un match retour bien
évidemment les instructions donc de très
grande formaté ont donc permis avec les
moyens exceptionnels déployés de
réaliser un nombre important
d'interpellation dans la nuit du 29 au
30 juin 988 interpellation du 30 juin au
1er juillet 1999 interpellation dans la
nuit du 1er juillet au 2 juillet 781
interpellation en tout c'est près de
3800 personnes qui ont été interpellées
et ainsi retirés des rues pour empêcher
de nuire et sans prendre bâtiment public
ou aux personnes
monsieur le ministre de la Justice est à
votre disposition évidemment pour les
suites pénales réservées mais chacun a
vu que elles ont été
forte et ferme d'autant plus remarquable
que un tiers des personnes interpellées
étaient des mineurs la moyenne d'âge
était entre 17 et 18 ans tout
interpellation confondues et plus de la
moitié d'entre eux n'étaient connu
d'aucun service de police et de justice
je voudrais ici travailler souligner le
travail qui a été fait par le ministère
de la justice par la circulaire pris par
monsieur le garde des sceaux et par les
décisions de justice pris par l'autorité
judiciaire qui a contribué bien
évidemment non seulement à renforcer le
travail des policiers et des gendarmes
qui ont pu dans l'urgence avoir un
travail d'investigation qui était
complexe lui permettent effectivement de
condamner très fortement des personnes
qui sont prenaient aux personnes ou bien
dans cette crise je veux relever
peut-être contrairement également à 2005
que les réseaux sociaux ont joué un rôle
extrêmement important c'est pourquoi
nous avons reçu le nom du Président de
la République et de la première ministre
avec le ministre en charge du numérique
les représentants en France et
principaux réseaux sociaux et nous leur
avons demandé de se montrer
particulièrement réactif dans le retrait
des contenus signalés en lien avec des
actes de violence conformément à la loi
et nous avons également pu compter sur
la coopération des grands sites de vente
en ligne pour retirer les objets
incendiaires de leur catalogue le sujet
des mortiers était particulièrement
présent vous le savez bien pendant ces
émeutes urbaines la plateforme Pharos de
la police judiciaire a parlé aurait été
très mobilisée plus de 2000 signalements
de contenu illicites ont été pris en
compte 2032 exactement ce qui a permis
de contribuer à initier des centaines de
procédures judiciaires à identifier de
nombreux auteurs d'infraction qui sont
encore d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans un
processus d'interpellation
ces différents facteurs associés au fait
que la police judiciaire a été associée
dès le début aux attentes faites contre
les personnes ou contre les biens a
permis de mettre la police technique et
scientifique au début de chaque affaire
ce qui aurait relevé classiquement
peut-être d'un travail de PJ de
commissariat ou de gendarmerie mobile
accompagné par la police judiciaire de
très nombreuses interpellations 345 ont
été faites postérieurement aux émeutes
et une très grande partie des
méfaits qui ont été constatés ont pu
connaître au moins un de leurs auteurs à
être confondus devant la justice grâce à
l'exploitation de la vidéoprotection qui
a été particulièrement efficace dans
cette période et on a d'ailleurs vu une
différence entre les communes qui avait
installé les caméras vidéoprotection et
celle qu'il ne l'avaient pas faite
évidemment l'installation et la
mobilisation de la police technique et
scientifique comme je l'ai dit la police
judiciaire
permettez-moi de remercier une nouvelle
fois les élus régulièrement les mers qui
ont mobilisé toutes les ressources et
notamment leur police municipale qui ont
payé un lourd tribu devant les
difficultés et les agressions les
insultes mais aussi des menaces en
dehors de leur service pour accompagner
la réponse de l'État ayant été maire et
connaissant bien sûr la police
municipale je sais que ce n'est pas de
gaieté de cœur qu'un maire contribue
rappelait ses agents à aller empêcher de
partir en congé ou les utiliser
évidemment dans un lien de travail avec
le ministère de l'Intérieur pour une
police qui dont c'est pas le quotidien
mais sans les politiciens plus de
difficultés évidemment à rétablir cette
ordre public dans les temps que records
que vous avez évoqué monsieur de
président dès la fin de sédiments
urbaines au gouvernement s'employés donc
très rapidement et ceux d'autorité du
président de la République a pensé le
temps d'après en prenant les mesures
d'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales et singulièrement la
réparation des caméras de
vidéoprotection qui ont été attaqué en
premier lieu de façon coordonnée par les
émeut vous avez vu les annonces de 20
millions d'euros faites dès cette année
pour réparer reconstruire les 1000
caméras de vidéoprosection qui ont été
supprimés ou attaqués à plus long terme
la réponse ne pourra évidemment pas être
une réponse de sécurité quand des
adolescents de 11 ou 12 ans attaquent au
mortier des policiers pays des magasins
parfois accompagnés
qui peuvent répondre à cette question
mais c'est l'ensemble de la société je
crois que chacun ici en convient je
voudrais aussi remercier depuis le 6
juillet nous avons donné l'instruction
au préfet en lien avec l'autorité
judiciaire est mise des comptes publics
Gabriel Attal pour les douanes la
multiplication des contrôles dans les
départements frontaliers de véhicules
ils ont à prévenir l'implantation
d'articles pyrotechnique qu'on appelle
mortier destiniens usage illégal nous
avons multiplié les opérations de
contrôle vous aurez constaté que ces
saisies étaient extrêmement importantes
puis qu'entre le 6 juillet et le 15
juillet plus de 160 000 saisies ont été
faites sur tout le territoire national
avec une usage d'artifice contre les
forces sécurité intérieure et les
bâtiments publics pendant les 13 et 14
juillet qu'on diminué de 60% et chacun a
vu d'ailleurs un 13 et 14 juillet qui
connaît et c'est le paradoxe de notre
période
une soirée relativement calme à quelques
exceptions près bien évidemment
c'est très et 14 juillet ce dispositif
de sécurité qui a été reconduit à
pleinement joué puisque les incendies de
véhicules ont diminué de 21%, les
blessés au sein des forces de sécurité
et de pompiers ont baissé de 74% et dans
le même temps nous avons entrepris 252
interpellations de personnes qui
effectivement pouvaient s'en prendre au
bâtiment public ou aux personnes pour
répondre directement à votre question
monsieur le Président il est évident que
la conséquence ou les conséquences du
bobo de la sécurité sont en train de se
voir par la traduction budgétaire je
rappelle que l'année prochaine sera
notre première année budgétaire
concrétisation du bobo de la sécurité
mais un centre de disposition a été pris
en amont je pense bien évidemment la
construction systématique de centre de
tir par exemple pour les forces de
l'ordre ce qui n'est pas le cas ce qui
n'était pas le cas dans les commissaires
d'aujourd'hui qui les empêchent de tenir
leurs trois tirs administratifs puisque
60% vous le savez des policiers ou des
gendarmes font leurs trois tirs
administratifs classiques vous dire
évidemment que nous avons augmenté les
quatre mois de formation comme nous
l'avions dit dans une façon de 8 à 12
moi avec par exemple plus de 100% de
cours sur les techniques
d'interpellation ce qui n'était pas le
cas et les policiers qui sont
aujourd'hui où les gendarmes qui sont
aujourd'hui en école sont en train de
subir cette nouvelle formation et donc
ce sont qu'à partir de cette année que
les sorties d'écoles vont évidemment
être des conséquences du beaujol de la
sécurité et je veux évidemment dire que
les caméras piétons équipent
l'intégralité de la police nationale et
de la gendarmerie nationale dans les
conditions que vous connaissez il est
évident que la question qui s'est posée
pour le drame de Nanterre fait qu'il y a
une difficulté sur les motards qui ne
pouvaient pas porter leur caméra piéton
m'a-t-on dit du fait de leur équipement
de protection et donc c'était une
évidemment une bévue de ne pas l'avoir
vu auparavant et je me donnais
évidemment instruction au directeur
général de la police nationale et auprès
de police pour quelque chose soit changé
d'ici la fin de l'année bien évidemment
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
Monsieur Thomas Rudy gossez la parole
pour deux minutes
et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il y a
trois semaines notre pays était frappé
sur l'ensemble du territoire par de
violentes émeturbaines perpétées par des
individus résolus en découdre avec les
forces de l'ordre et à s'en prendre aux
institutions républicaines aux élus et à
pied des commerces face à l'épreuve et
face à ces violences d'une ampleur
inédite la police la gendarmerie on
montre on fait montre d'un courage et
d'un dévouement exemplaire pour défendre
nos mairies nos écoles nos commissariats
722 policiers gendarmes ont été blessés
auxquels s'ajoutent 35 pompiers et je
souhaite le rappeler notre total soutien
face à cela des responsables politiques
de la France insoumise ont refusé de
condamner les ébutiers et non cessé de
jeter de l'huile sur le feu nos
concitoyens tout est consternés face à
cette irresponsabilité car lorsque l'on
exploite ainsi les colères on sort de
l'arc républicain comme la cyber madame
la Première ministre le constat de ces
émeutes monsieur le ministre est celui
d'un moment les violences changent de
dimension les forces de l'ordre ont
essuyé des milliers de tirs de mortiers
d'artifices et parfois même des tirs de
fusil à pompe en réaction monsieur vous
avez déployé 45000 policiers gendarmes
soit 40% des effectifs des forces de
l'ordre française appuyées par des
éléments d'élite tels le GIGN l'abberry
et les raids parmi les forces déployées
je n'oublierai pas les forts les polices
municipales vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre qui ont été mobilisés en
deuxième rideau et en appui de notre
police nationale ainsi dans mon
département le Rhône la mer socialiste
de Vaulx-en-Velin ou le maire LR de
Rillieux-la-Pape ont réalisé un travail
partenariale de grande qualité avec la
préfecture et avec le DDSP
malheureusement tel ne fut pas le cas à
Lyon ou le maire écologiste a refusé
d'apporter le concours de sa police
municipale monsieur le ministre Allonnes
de ces événements quel serait les points
à améliorer selon vous dans le continuum
de sécurité face à de telles violences
de même quel bilan faites-vous de la
coordination entre les différents
services police nationale police
municipale et gendarmerie je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Yoann Gillet
ça fonctionne monsieur le ministre des
émeutes tout en Basel le pays chacun a
pu constater la violence des émeutiers
leur désirs de piller de détruire les
symboles de la République voire même de
tuer nos compatriotes ont été sidérés de
voir que de jeunes adultes voire de très
jeunes adolescents ont activement
participé à ces émeutes les Français ont
été moins de toutes ces exactions et
réclament à juste titre des actes il
s'interroge tout aussi légitimement sur
le profil des émeutiers car si nous
voulons tirer des conséquences de ces
émeutes si nous voulons tirer les
conséquences de ces événements
dramatiques il faut il convient
d'obtenir d'abord et d'identifier les
émeutiers alors monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur je ne vais pas passer par
quatre chemins pouvez-vous nous
communiquer des informations précises
sur le profil socioprofessionnel des
émeutiers parmi les délinquants arrêtés
quel est le pourcentage d'individus
étrangers et quels sont leurs
nationalités parmi eux combien sont des
binationaux et quelles sont ses business
parmi les mineurs ou jeunes adultes
combien ont des parents de nationalités
étrangères et combien sont des
binationaux parmi les mineurs combien
sont des scolarisés parmi ces
délinquants quelle est la proportion de
ceux qui sont sans activité étudiante ou
professionnelle combien touche eux ou
leur famille pour les mineurs les
mini-masso le RSA les allocations CAF
etc monsieur le ministre vous l'aurez
compris je vous demande une pleine
transparence vous ne réglerez pas le
problème tant que vous refuserez d'être
transparent et surtout tant que vous
nierez la réalité tant que vous tenterez
de faire croire aux Français que les
émeutiers s'appellent Matteo et Kevin
bref vous ne réglerez pas le problème
tant que vous ferez l'impasse sur les
conséquences de l'immigration massive
dont les Français ne veulent plus merci
merci Monsieur Jean-Philippe Niort
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 19 novembre
2020 Michel zeclerc un citoyen comme
vous et moi compatriote martiniquais
vivant dans l'Hexagone était violemment
et gratuitement tabassé par quatre
policiers alors qui se rendait sur son
lieu de travail en décembre 2020 en
Guadeloupe monsieur Jean-Claude
Jean-Pierre monsieur Claude Jean-Pierre
âgé de 67 ans Mouret à la suite de
contrôle policier et le 29 juin dernier
le jeune Naël 17 ans mouray décide d'un
tir mortel d'un policier lors d'un
contrôle dans ce fait policier ou c'est
fait d'armes heureusement que les vidéos
ont parlé
l'ivrons une vérité crue difficile à
tronquer ces vidéos contre disent les
affaires siens relayées à grand l'enfant
médiatique tendance à nier les
contrôleurs faciès et les violences
policières les actes racistes sont
perpétrés quotidiennement en France tout
comme les discours racistes sont procès
quotidiennement dans cette Assemblée
nationale la liste des victimes de ces
méfaits est longue
dans nos territoires dit d'outre-mer
laboratoire de répression
en 1967 87 guadeloupéen qui réclamaient
leurs doigts sont tombés sous les balles
des forces de l'ordre en Martinique en
74 deux ouvriers ont été assassinés le
préfet étant ayant ordonné de tirer sous
la foule sans discernement c'est fait
têtu et criminant les forces de la
République que vous soutenez sans
réserve ce sont bien déroulés dans ce
territoire ancienne colonie avec une
férocité rarement atteinte dans
l'histoire de la férocité là où les
populations ont la mélanine la plus
colorée de cela et de cela pas de
meilleur coule pas et encore moins
dommage à la nation nul trace non plus
dans les livres d'histoire simple oublie
mépris ou déni assumer n'y voyez-vous
pas la preuve de violence policière
institutionnalisées systémique la
délinquance de certains jeunes la
responsabilité parentale le choc de
civilisation ne saurait être votre
mandat monsieur le ministre
vous merci êtes-vous prêt je termine
êtes-vous prêt à briser
Monsieur
Eric Peugeot
merci président monsieur le ministre fin
juin 4 nuits Durand notre pays a été
frappé meurtri par des émeutes d'une
violence inouïe attaque des symboles de
la république des figures d'autorité que
sont nos forces de l'or de nos
institutions agressions d'élus pillage
de commerce au temps d'atteintes à notre
État de droit injustifiable et
inexclusable rien ne peut justifier un
tel déferlement face à ces violents
urbaines de nombreuses polices
municipales et vous en avez parlé
troisième force de sécurité du pays ont
été sollicitées pour appuyer les forces
de sécurité nationale investi de fait
d'une mission régalienne de maintien de
l'ordre ils ont pris toutes leurs parts
aux côtés de la police nationale et de
la gendarmerie par leur
professionnalisme et leur courage à
l'interpellation des 3800 délinquants
pendant les nuits d'émeutes les
policiers municipaux sont et sont
devenus des forces de sécurité
incontournables voici monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez nous indiquer le nombre de
polissimunicipaux en service pendant les
émeutes ainsi que pendant les festivités
du 14 juillet le nombre de blessés dans
leur rang ainsi que la répartition
territor iale de ses effectifs enfin
quelle stratégie partenariale
envisagez-vous de mettre en œuvre afin
de rendre cette coopération et cette
complémentarité encore plus
opérationnelle et envisagez-vous de
mettre à l'honneur le dévouement de nos
policiers municipaux nos mères l'appel
de leurs vœux merci
Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
nous avons tous été ça a été dit sidéré
et individuellement et collectivement
par l'ampleur de l'explosion de violence
qui s'est déchaîné qui a embrasé nombre
de quartiers de nos villes entre le 27
juin et 5 juillet dernier c'est 10 jours
de violence incontrôlables et
imprévisible nous avons été
choqués ça a été dit par les atteintes
aux personnes notamment les forces de
l'ordre service de secours auxquels nous
apportons un soutien et puis également
aux élus locaux
les dernières estimations sur les biens
matériels sont tout à fait édifiantes et
je veux dire que chacun sur son
territoire a assisté impuissant assez
déchaînements de violence et ainsi dans
mon département par exemple de la Loire
où on a pu noter un bilan extrêmement
lourd je pense à Saint-Étienne mais
aussi dans ma circonscription la ville
de Rive-de-Gier je dois dire que les
commerces détruits les mairies détruites
se montrent à quel point la situation
pouvait paraître incontrôlable jusqu'à
préoccuper énormément nos concitoyens
les élus et tous les acteurs
heureusement les services de l'État
déconcentrés ont été très réactifs et je
crois qu'on doit s'en féliciter ils se
sont mobilisés très vite aux côtés des
élus pour les accompagner et la
compagnie municipalité pour veiller à la
continuité des services publics et
autant de faire ce peu rétablir l'ordre
public nous allons adopter d'ici la fin
de la semaine un texte militant le
gouvernement accéléré la reconstruction
des bâtiments des gravés lors des
violences urbaines face aux attentes
légitimes des mères nous serions
preneurs d'éléments de méthode et sur la
procédure éventuellement le calendrier
sur la vidéo surveillance vous avez
souligné l'importance son importance
nous disons que malheureusement tous les
territoires ne sont pas équipés et
lorsqu'ils le sont les images sont pas
exploitées en temps réel avez-vous des
éléments là aussi pour permettre une
meilleure articulation entre les
différents acteurs publics et une
meilleure efficacité du dispositif merci
monsieur rogerico
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues d'abord
dire qu'effectivement même si la colère
qui a suivi la mort de Noël est tout à
fait compréhensible rien ne peut excuser
évidemment les péages qui ont lieu par
la suite et encore moins les attaques
contre tous les symboles les symboles
pardon du service public alors par
coïncidence il se trouve qu'il y a
quelques minutes avant le début de cette
réunion nous étions en audition de
Madame politic vapeur qui est professeur
de civilisation britannique
contemporaine à la Sorbonne sur la
mission d'information sur
l'activisme violent et notamment les
violences urbaines et c'était très
intéressant parce que Madame schnappeur
nous a décrit véritablement un autre
monde un autre bombe un autre monde
pardon à quelques centaines de
kilomètres d'ici au Royaume-Uni non pas
qu'il ne s'y passe rien bien entendu
mais où elle nous a expliqué que le
discours au plus haut niveau dans la
police mais aussi au gouvernement est
très axé sur la proximité et surtout par
exemple puisqu'on parle de manifestation
ce soir et surtout sur la protection du
droit à manifester un exemple pendant le
couronnement les cérémonies du
couronnement du roi Charles un militant
républicain a été arrêté émis en garde à
vue ce qui a été considéré comme un
véritable scandale au Royaume-Uni alors
c'est une introduction pour poser le
tableau mais je voudrais vous poser deux
questions monsieur le ministre il a été
beaucoup question de la loi de février
2017 sur la loi Cazeneuve sur
l'utilisation des armes par les
policiers en état de légitime défense
nous avons demandé une mission
d'évaluation de cette loi est-ce qu'à
titre personnel vous pensez que cette
loi va être évaluée comment qu'est-ce
qu'il a pas été compris dans cette loi
comment elle pourrait être améliorée
éventuellement et deuxième question
pensez-vous que la formation nos
policiers doivent être modifiées modifié
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait changer dans
cette formation et pas seulement
l'allongement de l'ignorer de formation
mais sur quel Couvin elle pourrait être
améliorée de manière à éviter demain les
excès qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu
Monsieur Didier Le Maire
monsieur le ministre dans le contexte de
violence urbaine que notre pays a
rencontré le calme est fort heureusement
revenu il faut saluer la fermeté dont
vous avez fait preuve par l'action
coordonnée du gouvernement et notamment
des ministères de l'Intérieur et de la
justice je vais évidemment rendre
hommage à nos policiers gendarmes et
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été fortement
sollicités et en première ligne et j'ai
envie de dire une fois de plus monsieur
le ministre ma question concerne
l'équipement des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour que nos sapeurs-pompiers
puissent intervenir en toute sécurité en
ses circonstances ils ont besoin des
forces de l'ordre et j'ai une pensée
pour mes anciens collègues pompiers de
Mulhouse qui comme tant d'autres ont
vécu un odieux guetapan qui aurait pu
mal se solder
dans ce contexte de violence urbaine des
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
ont été attaqués or il semble que les
équipements de protection pour le
maintien de l'ordre ne soient pas
présent en quantité suffisante alors
qu'il est impératif qu'il puisse se
protéger dans leur casernements mais
aussi pour venir renforcer les effectifs
dans les secteurs les plus impactés de
même la généralisation des caméras
embarquées dans les véhicules ne
permettrait pas de faciliter l'enquête
judiciaire pour intercepter puis juger
les auteurs de ses méfaits abjects je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais pas répéter ce que on
dit l'ensemble de nos collègues tout le
monde ici regrette condamne le fait que
les quartiers les plus et moins dotés en
service public les moins dotés tout
court et les plus défavorisés soit ceux
qui et le plus souffert des casser des
destructions on le dit avec des mots
différents on le dit avec des styles
différents on l'exprime de façon
différente mais tout le monde se rejoint
dessus ce serait bien que l'on puisse
sortir de ces attaques permanentes j'ai
en tête l'audition que nous avons eu la
semaine dernière avec l'iggn et l'IGPN
je me souviens que dans cette audition
nous avons acté le fait que critiquer
c'était quelque chose de constructif et
que c'est ce qui permettait d'avancer
j'espère que vos réponses seront à la
hauteur de cette capacité de construire
j'ai deux questions rapides monsieur le
ministre
d'une part sur l'audition de la semaine
dernière ou
l'iggn nous a rappelé qu'il y avait eu
zéro mort en 2022 de leur côté par refus
d'obtempérer s'opposant au 13 morts côté
police que c'était pas par hasard mais
le fruit d'un travail coordonné avec
l'ensemble de la gendarmerie pour former
les agents au tir aux situations
difficiles pour éviter aux agents de se
retrouver dans des situations qui les
poursuivent tout le reste de leur vie et
permettre à l'ensemble de la population
de se retrouver dans le traitement qui
en ait été fait deuxième question c'est
c'est la question de l'usage et non
celle de la loi pour sortir un peu des
questions précédentes et enfin je
m'interroge quand je vois le trajet de
certains des policiers en particulier
celui qui incriminé dans le tir qui a
causé la mort de ce jeune homme
il provient il était peu de temps
auparavant à la bravème et avant ça la
CSI 93 je rappelle que la Bravet m'a été
créée alors même par les agents de la
CSI 93 alors même où les procès étaient
en cours contre la CSI 93 dissoute
depuis pour des actes très graves
monsieur le ministre comment se fait-il
que dans un esprit de
envers les forces de l'ordre les
pompiers et toutes les personnes qui
sont intervenues pour protéger nos
compatriotes je pense aux élus et tout
particulièrement à Stéphanie 29 là vous
l'avez cité mère de Pontoise qui a été
très choqué parce qu'elle a vécu cette
semaine là tout porte à croire qu'il
s'agit d'une géographie nouvelle dont on
n'a pas l'habitude qui s'est constitué
un mouvement violent après la question
s'intéresse donc au moyen humain et aux
ressources dont nous disposés en cas de
mobilisation massive que pouvez-vous
dire à ce sujet
nous apprenons ce jour que plus de 1000
condamnations ont été prononcées avec
près de 600 détention
aussi ma seconde question s'intéresse au
profil des amitiés qu'en déduisent vos
services enfin troisième question pour
faire rapide envisagez-vous des
adaptations vis-à-vis de la doctrine
d'intervention et je ne serai conclure
sans rappeler votre implication et vous
remercier de tout ce que vous avez fait
jusqu'à maintenant merci monsieur le
ministre pour répondre à cette première
série de questions
merci monsieur le Président alors la
question de surudigose comment améliorer
le continuum de sécurité c'est une
question auquel on a je crois déjà
répondu dans la loi mais surtout le
Conseil constitutionnel a répondu sur
les souhaits du gouvernement et du
Parlement parce que je rappelle que
c'était une proposition de Loisy par
deux de vos collègues notamment
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel Fauvergue sur le
fait qu'il fallait donner davantage de
moyens de police municipal ce qui me
semble-t-il et du bon sens dans leur
action et dans ce qu'on appelle ce
continent de sécurité qu'a dit le
Conseil constitutionnel vous le savez
même d'un point de vue expérimental il
n'a pas autorisé le fait que les polices
municipales et des moyens
supplémentaires notamment d'action de
police judiciaire de passage de fichiers
de regards d'un certain nombre d'actes
d'enquête ou de considérer comme étant
des actes d'enquêtes au motifs qui ne
sont pas sous l'autorité du procureur de
la République ce que sont les policiers
des gendarmes dont je voudrais appeler
ici que mise en intérieur les embauches
les de les former c'est de les équiper
peut donner à certains nombre de moyens
d'administratifs mais ils agissent
toujours y compris lorsqu'ils font des
contrôles d'identité sous l'autorité
bien évidemment du procureur de la
République et donc si nous voulons
modifier de nouveau ce contient de
sécurité pour renforcer la coopération
police gendarmerie police municipale en
dehors des moyens nouveaux ce que vous
souhaitez dans votre question donnée et
qui reste à la disposition des mers
puisqu'il y a quasiment je caricature
mais autant de police festivals
puisqu'il y a ceux qui décident de pas
en avoir ce qui décide d'avoir une
spécifique à l'armée il y a des types
d'armements différents il y a du travail
évidemment différent sur les political
donc il y a pas une police municipale
mais des polices municipales il nous
faut deux choses soit modifier la
Constitution
pour permettre une exception pour les
polices municipales
ce qui me paraît pas être alors du jour
et peut-être est-ce un peu excessif mais
pourquoi pas en discuter en tout cas ça
peut pas se faire droit législatif
constant si j'ose dire ou alors il faut
que les maires acceptent de mettre à
disposition du procureur de la
République leur police municipale
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont comme le mis à
l'intérieur employeur mais qui ne sont
pas ce qui commande de fait les polices
municipales puisque le maire a beaucoup
plus d'actions vers la police municipale
que mise à l'intérieur on en a avec ses
policiers puisque par définition les
actes d'enquête ne sont pas faites à la
demande mise à l'intérieur mais sont
faites à la demande de l'autorité
judiciaire donc si nous voulons
améliorer le costume de sécurité je
pense que ça a débat public qui monte
beaucoup de merlements des et c'est
entendable nous sommes allés au bout du
droit constante nous pourrions faire je
pense que chacun des témoin le Conseil
était extrêmement clair et pourtant nous
avions dit des expérimentations à faire
autour d'expérience dans certaines
communes avec un encadrement franchement
nous avons été pas très je crois que le
droit a été pour le coup et tout le
monde en a convenu et beaucoup de gens
de voter cette disposition bien bien
bien fait ben voilà il faut changer la
constitution ou alors il faut que les
maires acceptent que leur police soit
autorité des procureur je crois pas que
maire accepte que la police soit
autorité des producteurs de la
République voilà en tout cas j'en ai
j'en ai vu aucun qui avait la main pour
le proposer donc j'en conclus donc que
soit il faut rester dans cette situation
soit il faut modifier la Constitution
sur la coordination police nationale du
gendarmerie nationale moi je voudrais
remarquer que on va parler lors du bobo
la sécurité monsieur le Président j'ai
depuis trois ans que je me disais
intérieure je me suis beaucoup exprimé
dans cette question ici je pense que
c'était illustratif de ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est-à-dire que les
zones polissent les zones gendarmerie
n'existent que dans la tête des
policiers des gendarmes des préfets
puisque s'il existe un article du code
général des collectivités territoriales
qui indiquent que au dessus d'un certain
nombre d'habitants plus de 20000 ou
25000 je ne sais plus c'est plutôt une
zone police plutôt de gendarmerie on
sait qu'ailleurs qu'il y a des
exceptions ensuite par ailleurs on voit
en outre-mer qui a des communes qui sont
à 50 000 60000 habitants qui ont une
zone gendarmerie et puis par ailleurs
évidemment il n'y a pas de délimitation
puisque il est à droite poursuite bien
sûr entre frontières si j'ose dire d'un
même département ces zones polices et
gendarmerie sont à proscrire pour
atteindre les buts de sécurité que veut
se fixer le préfet sous l'autorité du
ministre de l'intérieur c'est à dire que
les policiers peuvent aller dans un
jardinerie et les gendarmes peuvent
aller en zone police ça paraît la
tautologie mais évidemment ce n'était
pas évident donc j'ai mis en place qu'on
appelle les corates c'est les préfets
qui réunissent puisque sont eux les
autorités civiles se sont ni et
policiers des gendarmes qui dirigent
leur force mais bien le préfet ou la
préfète les policiers les gendarmes pour
dire bah voilà on a besoin de gendarmes
ce soir ou cet après-midi ou demain ou
telle opération en zone police et des
gens ou des policiers ils ont des
gendarmerie ça arrive très rarement si
tu arrives rarement et c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé quotidiennement pendant ces
quatre jours comment on a pu tenir notre
terrain c'est que nous avons demandé au
psychique de vos départements d'aller
dans les villes et notamment la ville
qui pouvait pas avoir d'unité de force
mobiles ils ont fait un travail
formidable et on a demandé évidemment à
des gendarmes de territoriale soit de
remplacer leurs collègues policiers dans
des circonscriptions de police où il n'y
avait pas de drames de ce fait de ces
émeutes urbaines pour libérer des
policiers nationaux pour venir dans les
autres zones de police ou alors devenir
carrément dans les zones polices pour
aider leurs collègues de la police
nationale et ça c'est fait sans
difficulté et je dois d'ailleurs que
nous le faisons quotidiennement grâce
aux unités de Forceville puisque 80% des
interventions des gendarmes mobiles sont
en zone police et donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut qu'on prenne cette ce très
bon manière de bien fonctionner quand il
y a un drame malheureusement pour le
faire de manière générale quand il y a
la lutte contre la drogue quand il y a
l'évidence intrafamiliale quand il y a
des dossiers à traiter rien n'empêche
aux policiers dans une gendarmerie aux
gendarme d'être dans un dans un
commissariat voilà c'est vraiment des
barrières mentales et moi je préfère de
loin qu'on travaille dans cette forme
d'action que d'imaginer un renouveau
redécoupage des zones politiques
gendarmerie vous m'écrivez parfois pour
dire moi j'aimerais passer dans un
gendarmerie aux autres police on peut
toujours en discuter ici ou là pour des
raisons d'affectation de personnes parce
qu'il relève du statut pour les
gendarmes et je sais plus facile de les
envoyer que les policiers on y reviendra
si vous le souhaitez mais je trouve ça
plus intelligent me semble-t-il de pas
payer de nouveaux locaux de ne pas
déménager des familles mais dire aux
policiers et aux gendarmes vous êtes
dans le même département sous l'autorité
du préfet et vous utilisent comme bon
lui semble évidemment en lien avec vos
officiers traitant bien sûr donc ça
c'est intéressant parmi les rétextes on
va évidemment travailler sur ce qui
s'est passé je pense qu'on en tirera des
conclusions très opérationnelles et les
préfets qui n'ont pas utilisé leur
korate le premier jour on se sont ceux
qui ont eu le plus de difficultés voilà
donc au début j'avais dit au préfet vous
l'utilisez si vous le souhaitez comme
j'ai vu tout le monde n'avait pas fait
que ça s'était mal passé après je suis
passé du mode démocratique comme de
directif voilà et comme tout le monde
l'a fait ça s'est mieux passé vous
l'avez vu le deuxième jour sur le
la question de Monsieur le Député gilet
alors il y a dans votre question des
choses auxquelles je peux apporter des
réponses et d'autre ok je peux pas
répondre puis à une question plus
philosophique je vous ai donné ce que je
peux vous communiquer moi je vous ai dit
sur 3800 interpellations il y a un tiers
de mineur l'âge moyen est passé de 17
ans à peu près 17 ans à peu près 18 ans
à la fin des interpellations parce qu'on
a vu que c'était pas totalement les
mêmes interpellés à la fin au début
notamment au début c'était plutôt des
atteintes au service public aux
personnes à la fin c'était plutôt du
pillage de commerce où il y a eu plus
d'adultes enfin 17 18 ans en moyenne sur
3800 c'est quand même pas à peu près au
monde j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de vous
dire que 10% des personnes interpellées
n'étaient pas de nationalité française
ce qui veut donc dire que 90% d'entre
sont nationalité française le mise à
l'intérieur n'a aucun droit et n'a aucun
moyen de savoir le nombre de binationaux
monsieur député il faut que que vous le
saviez j'y arrive monsieur j'y arrive
monsieur député et je vous l'ai dit
et je vous l'ai dit ce député 60%
d'entre eux n'étaient pas connu des
services de police donc mineur 90% de
français et 60% connu de 15 services de
police ou de ou dans le jardinerie même
pour une infraction qui pourrait
bénigne et c'est le contraire d'un
délinquance de d'habitude la délinquance
d'habitude c'est plutôt des gens qu'on
connaît dans les services de police
essaye de gendarmerie bon alors après
moi monsieur le député je n'ai pas
la volonté de de porter des statistiques
ethniques
je n'ai jamais aimé les statistiques
ethniques et j'ai toujours considéré
qu'un Français était un français et
qu'on ne veut pas compter puisque
m'avait demandé de savoir qui était
d'origine étrangère le nombre de
grands-parents qui n'étaient pas
français parce que je crois que ça on
rentrerait dans une république qui est
pas la mienne et en tout cas j'espère
pas la nôtre pour une partie d'entre
vous ça c'est mon premier point monsieur
le monsieur député le deuxième point je
voulais vous dire c'est que il est des
moments où à la fois la caricature du
propos dans un moment où le pays
connaissait ses difficultés
la mauvaise foi ou alors le manque de
travail mais de votre côté j'imagine que
c'est plutôt la mauvaise foi en tout cas
je vais vous faire ce procès et
troisièmement le fait que la réalité se
rappelle à vous puisque depuis la presse
s'intéresse à cette question et n'a pas
donné de repos que j'ai eu dans la
commission des Lois du Sénat je vous ai
dit et j'ai dit au présent
m'avait interpellé qu'il serait faux de
dire que 100% des métiers et des
délinquants étaient étrangers ou pour
entrer dans votre malheureuse rhétorique
d'origine étrangère ce n'est pas vrai il
y en avait une grande partie
mais ce n'est pas 100% et j'ai eu accès
monsieur parce que c'est mon travail de
mise à l'intérieur à l'intégralité des
interpellations qui ont été faites je
peux vous dire Monsieur le Député que
vous avez tort vous avez tort vous qui
n'avez pas accès à ces informations et
qui manifestement souhaité calquer votre
idéologie sur la réalité alors qu'il me
semble que la réalité de les guider vers
présentant du peuple lorsqu'il parle et
qu'ils ont le nom de parler que ce n'est
pas vrai il y a une grande diversité
dans les profils que nous avons
interpellés et ce serait faux monsieur
le député mais vous pouvez tourner la
tête je vous dis la réalité vous pouvez
renier le réel il y a cette difficulté
et voyez je pense qu'on je vais répondre
tout de suite à Monsieur à Monsieur
minor et je connais je veux lui dire
tout mon respect évidemment je pense que
vous avez le même cheminement si vous me
permettez évidemment très différent vous
systématisez une réponse parce que vous
avez envie que ce soit systématique de
même monsieur Milan il n'y a pas tous
les policiers ou la police nationale qui
est raciste vous avez cité trois faits
absolument affreux je rappelle
d'ailleurs que pour le cas du policier
qui a tiré sur le jeune Naël tout en
ayant eu beau je pense extrêmement clair
et à mon avis pas conforme effectivement
ni au droit ni à la formation
prodigieuse policier il est toujours
toujours présumé innocent et même s'il a
des indices graves et concordant parce
qu'il est mis en examen et c'est le
droit il n'est pas condamné donc je veux
aussi respecter sa présence comme dans
toute action et monsieur le député il
est faux de dire que il y a un racisme
systémique de la police nationale et
notamment pour les pour les pour les
gens qui viennent des Antilles dire
c'est une insulte à tous les antillais
et vous savez qu'ils ont extrêmement
nombreux vous m'écrivez d'ailleurs
quasiment toutes les semaines pour
demander à ce que des policiers que vous
connaissez sans doute rejoignent votre
votre territoire il y a des policiers
des gendarmes antillais à qui on peut
pas faire si on partait de ce principe
le le procès de racisme ou alors on
serait assez loin me semble-t-il de la
réalité donc je crois que des deux côtés
si on pouvait arrêter de systématiser et
de tirer un enseignement général sur des
actes qui sont insupportables et c'est
pas parce qu'un étranger commet des
actes de délinquance que tous les
étrangers comme les algues d'intenses il
y a aussi beaucoup d'étrangers qui ont
sont intervenus pour protéger des
policiers des gendarmes pendant cette
période qui ont protégé j'ai eu
l'exemple d'un buraliste dans une
commune de provinces où ces deux
personnes d'origine étrangère monsieur
député vous n'écoutez plus parce que là
je pense que évidemment ça va loin de
votre idéologie et votre réalité mais je
vous dis salut on les salut on les
monsieur le député c'est deux personnes
étrangères qui ont aidé ce buraliste à
sauver sa cargaison voilà vous ne l'avez
pas dit c'est dommage donc systématisons
pas et pour vous répondre complètement
parce que moi je sens que ce discours
effectivement peut faire naître chez nos
concitoyens en écho qui évidemment et je
crois nauséabond j'ai demandé au
président de la République ce que n'a
jamais fait mystère de l'intérieur que
nous saisissions le ministère
d'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
le ministère de la Justice et ministère
de l'Intérieur pour que l'intégralité
des documents puisque ce sont des
documents désormais qui sont sur des
procédures judiciaires puis cette donnée
à des chercheurs à des personnes qui
vont être observateur éloignées de nos
ministères qui ne sont pas
fonctionnaires et qui pourront je crois
que monsieur le Président ce serait une
bonne chose que vous les auditionnez
vous dire quels sont les profils de ces
métiers que nous devons comprendre
je voudrais vous dire qu'il y a des
moments où aussi on doit comprendre la
géographie de ses émeutes il y a des
quartiers que je connais très bien dans
mon département et dans ma commune qui
n'ont connu aucune aucune difficulté
aucune difficulté alors que ce sont les
quartiers quand j'étais mère qui était
voilà les plus chauds pour reprendre une
expression populaire et il y a des
quartiers extrêmement calme qui ne
connaissent pas la politique de la ville
qui ne connaissent pas d'immigrations
qui ne connaissent pas de personnes
d'origine étrangère en très grand nombre
pour reprendre votre rhétorique qui ont
connu des violences importantes voilà
donc je crois que la facilité n'est pas
bonne conseillère je vous conseillerais
de pas compter le nombre de
grands-parents qui auraient des origines
pour savoir qui est français parce que
ça nous rappelle les histoires qui sont
pas très positives un français est un
Français qu'ensuite il y ait des défauts
d'éducation de parents d'intégration de
logements d'urbanisme de sécurité oui
bien sûr c'est une évidence mais je
constate malheureusement que la
délinquance se résume pas à un prénom
pardon de vous avoir dérangé dans vos
certitudes
je voudrais dire à Monsieur monsieur le
député des Alpes-Maritimes pardon que
oui non les polices municipales leur
métier c'est pas de faire du maintien de
l'ordre et d'ailleurs il ne faut pas
qu'elle le fasse en revanche les polices
municipales peuvent tout à fait aider à
un certain nombre d'actions lorsqu'il y
a ce genre de choses à la demande du
préfet et quand les polices principales
ne le font pas le préfet pourrait
réquiditionner je ne vais pas proposé y
compris avec Monsieur le Maire de Lyon
dont l'attitude en effet nous a beaucoup
choqué puisqu'il a retiré de la voie
publique c'est le seul maire à l'avortée
les policiers municipaux tout en
réclamant d'ailleurs des unités de CRS
ce que nous avons évidemment envoyé à
Lyon d'ailleurs j'ai une bien noté que
CRS était bienvenu à Lyon je ce que je
veux vous dire Monsieur député c'est
qu'en revanche tu peux ici municipaux
ils doivent pouvoir aider l'action donc
pouvoir regarder les caméras
vidéoprotection tenir les postes bien
évidemment procéder ils peuvent le faire
à des interpellations vous le savez pas
dans un cadre de manifestation d'ordre
public mais de lutte contre délinquance
et autant nous n'avons pas utilisé le
premier jour parce que je vous l'ai dit
que nous pensions que c'était des
manifestations spontanées à encadrer
type ordre public pour muter nous
l'avons tous constaté excusez-moi à une
possibilité d'émeute et de délinquance
et qu'il s'agissait donc de violences
urbaines et à ce titre et festival
peuvent y participer non pas en ordre
public mais en intervention toujours
évidemment sous la coordination et
l'autorité du préfet selon les armes
qu'ils ont sur l'information qu'ils ont
sont les qualifications qu'ils ont il y
a eu ici ou là des mers qui les parents
ont dit au préfet moi ma police elle est
pas armée ma police elle est pas formée
à ça oui d'accord pour tenir le poste de
police municipale pour remplacer telle
ou telle garde pour tenir la mairie ça
sous un beau côté parce qu'on libère des
policiers qui pour le coup on fait autre
chose et puis il y a deux qui ont dit
ben ma police a des armée ma police elle
est elle est formée et elle pourrait
elle a parfois même des équipements vous
savez bien de lutte contre les violences
urbaines et elle peut elle peut accéder
alors après dans l'urgence ces
situations puisque 380
policiers nationaux des gendarmes de
sapeurs-pompiers et aux policiers
municipaux je les fais en région
parisienne je l'ai fait dans l'ordre
dans mon département je ferai ailleurs à
chaque fois je demande que des policiers
municipaux soit distingués et soit
présenté au même titre que les policiers
nationaux les gendarmes et si vous avez
des noms évidemment je suis preneur et
le ministère de l'Intérieur sera
distingué ces policiers municipaux
courageux sur la question
des caméras de vidéos protection elles
ont été je le dis au député mon nom
extrêmement efficace extrêmement
efficace elles ont été efficaces pour le
travail qu'a fait la police nationale la
gendarmerie nationale pour lutter contre
l'insécurité et les émeutes
elles ont été efficaces pour lever le
doute sur les pièges tendues parce qu'il
y a eu vous le savez bien des pièges
tendus notamment sapeurs-pompiers et
pour quand on appelle pour dire il y a
le feu au 8e étage en tel immeuble et
qu'on sait qu'il y a pas le feu 8e étage
dans de l'immeuble on se doute que si
les pompiers va c'est peut-être pour se
faire cailler c'est ça évite des
interpellations ça évite des baisser ça
a eu des problèmes et elles ont été
efficaces pour ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire la résolution
judiciaire des difficultés donc elles
ont été triplement efficaces ces caméras
et tous ceux qui disent que les caméras
n'ont pas été efficaces et là encore moi
j'ai demandé un RETEX pour savoir une
sorte de différence entre là où il y
avait beaucoup de caméras là il y en
avait pas beaucoup pour pouvoir voir si
effectivement on sera toujours ce débat
ici je le sais à l'Assemblée nationale
je pense que le président de la
commission des lois pourrait être
destinataire de ce de ces travaux et
peut-être auditionner les gens à qui
j'ai demandé un rapport sur cette
question que la première chose qu'on
fait les émeutiers c'est de casser ses
caméras à vie de protection donc si elle
n'était pas efficace ces caméras vidéo
protection pourquoi les émeutiers les
casseraient-ils en premier
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut désormais
se rendre dans des choses très concrètes
j'ai remarqué qu'il y a même des
parlementaires de la France insoumise
qui a réclamé des caméras de
vidéoprotection je les en remercie et
c'est vrai que c'est dommage que les
parents publics soient pas toujours les
paroles privées ou les courriers que je
reçois pour demander des subventions
dans tel ou tel circonscription je veux
réussir monsieur Vico que je partage pas
tout à fait on pourrait je suis pas
professeur et mérite à la Sorbonne et je
voudrais pas je n'étais pas votre
audition monsieur le député mais je suis
allé à Londres voilà quelques jours et
justement nous avons parlé de
couronnement de droit et
j'entends ce que vous dites républicain
mais ils n'ont pas la même vision
d'écologie radicale par exemple parce
que vous savez que je vous apprends
peut-être quelque chose de ce député
c'est qu'il y a une loi spécifique sur
l'écologie radicale en Grande-Bretagne
qui permet de faire des interpellations
en administratifs avant les
manifestations donc si votre modèle
c'est me proposer un texte contre
l'écologie radicale à la veille des gros
événements
donc faut tout prendre de l'Angleterre
alors d'accord très bien je constate que
je constate que vous reculez vous
reculez monsieur député alors après
c'est sûr et tout est tout à fait vrai
que la Grande-Bretagne a une autre façon
de gérer sa police on en a déjà parlé
pour plein de raisons il y a des
avantages des inconvénients je rappelle
que le modèle anglais est un modèle
américain sur une police fédérale
ce qui est une autre façon de faire vous
le savez bien et qui n'est pas je crois
non plus votre votre modèle a priori
donc qu'on en discute tout à fait voilà
mais je pense pas que l'Angleterre soit
non plus la panacée la panacée absolue
sur cette question même s'il y a
toujours à prendre et l'intelligence
partout son émission d'évaluation c'est
pas moins de prononcer sur ce que peut
faire ou pas le Parlement j'aurais trop
respectueux du travail des
parlementaires moi je suis toujours pour
qu'on évalue j'ai aucun problème pour
élever 2017 et si vous faites des choses
2017 je viendrai bien volontiers et tous
les services sont à votre disposition je
veux constater simplement que le le
discours est un peu étonnant sur la loi
de 2017 et je comprends pas les propos
excellents du Premier ministre Cazeneuve
le policier n'est manifestement je dis
manifestement parce qu'après aussi nos
sens pas respecté la loi de 2017
ni sa formation ni sa déontologie bon je
mets encore une fois des guillemets
parce que c'est pas moi de le dire à la
fin cette inspection générale mais j'ai
le droit en tant que employeur constaté
quand je demande aux gens dont c'est le
travail est-ce qu'il l'a fait c'est ce
que j'ai fait quand j'ai vu cette vidéo
qui m'a choqué personnellement mais dont
je voudrais savoir si effectivement
c'était conforme au droit ou pas ça peut
être choquant et confort droit et c'est
pour ça que le parlementaire c'est pour
changer le droit j'imagine tout le monde
m'a dit oui c'est choquant et ce n'est
pas conforme au droit a priori bien une
fois qu'on a dit ça
quand quelqu'un ne respecte pas la loi
quel est l'intérêt de changer la loi
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il changera de
comportement si quelqu'un fait du 180 km
alors sur l'autoroute et que c'est
marqué 130 penser que descendre à 120
n'empêchera de rouler à 180
donc qui ça évaluer la loi de 2017 parce
que peut-être que pour plein de raisons
elle est pas extrêmement claire elle ne
permet pas aux policiers aux gendarmes
d'intervenir dans de bonnes conditions
elle permet je reviendrai sur l'iggn
uniformisation pourquoi pas maintenant
ça fait 5 6 ans je pense que c'est
tellement important le tir administratif
que bien sûr vous avez que le policier
des titir il est très souvent mis en
garde à vue voilà c'est toujours un choc
de tirer encore plus évidemment tu es un
homme sans aucun doute mais je pense que
dans le cas précis monsieur le député il
faut bien comprendre que ce policier
n'aurait pas respecté le droit et donc
changer le droit dans cette position là
n'aurait à mon avis pas changé forcément
grand chose mais pour l'évaluation mais
pour l'évaluation je suis évidemment à
disposition du Parlement et c'est ce que
je souhaitais vous dire ce qui permet
peut-être de répondre à Madame Rogue
directement puisque m'a interpellé sur
la question de la différence entre la
gendarmerie et la police nationale j'ai
vu l'intervention de l'inspecteur
général de la
d'ailleurs il part en retraite dans
quelques jours et il est remplacé par un
magistrat d'ailleurs je voudrais dire
ici que j'aurais tenu ma promesse des
bobos la sécurité puisque vous avez une
magistrate désormais la tête de les GPN
et un magistrat à la tête de
l'inspection générale la gendarmerie
nationale ce qui n'a jamais existé dans
les deux maisons de la police et de la
gendarmerie donc je réponds en même
temps évidemment et vous allez entendu
la magistrate qui était patronne de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale moi moi ce que je vais
constater c'est deux choses madame la
député la première c'est que la police a
gendarmerie ne sont pas tout à fait dans
les mêmes zones de délinquance
et il y a des refus de tempérés dans le
gendarmerie bien évidemment mais on ne
peut pas dire sérieusement que les
policiers et les gendarmes connaissent
les mêmes types de délinquance
deuxièmement il c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont
pas la même formation et j'ai entendu ce
que m'a dit c'est ce qu'a dit
l'inspecteur général je trouve que ce
weekend le weekend qui a suivi votre
audition il y a eu deux refus
d'obtempérer en zone gendarmerie qui
sont remontés à quelques centimes à
l'intérieur et il y a eu des tirs
administratifs de la gendarmerie
nationale et on a eu à pleine Fougères
en Ille-et-Vilaine où les gendarmes ont
utilisé leur arme administrative sur un
véhicule qui a démarré à la vue de la
patrouille le binôme du militaire visé à
fait usage de son arme 5 fois en
direction des pneus du véhicule qui a
pas qui est parvenu à s'échapper pas de
laisser chez les gendarmes résultat des
tirs inconnus OK dans lequel judiciaire
pour savoir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
puis à bandel
donc vous savez que cette en outre-mer
usage des armes par un militaire de la
gendarmerie nationale se joue à 9h30 par
deux patrouilleurs de des gendarmes
mobiles de Chambéry qui est en poste de
contrôle routier et ils ont été victimes
dans opérer le gendarme mobile attiré
avec son arme de service sur la portière
conséquence du tir inconnu de militaire
et blessé donc moi j'ai entendu votre
l'audition je ne me permettrai pas de
corriger les propos d'inspecteur général
je constate que ce weekend il n'y a pas
eu tiers de la police nationale mais il
tire la gendarmerie nationale
inutile sur les véhicules et que ceci à
quelques centimètres près à quelques
secondes près aurait pu causer et même
fait
oui non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que il serait il serait juste de dire
que c'est un pas la même délinquance et
que deux bon voilà parfois il arrive que
la réalité corrige un peu ce qui a pu
vous être dit mais évidemment des propos
sont totalement sont totalement libres
sur la question
de des caméras embarquées pardon
monsieur le député
j'avoue que la deuxième question c'était
sûr
ah oui sur les parcours pardon
je vais répondre à votre question
rapidement
sur donc la question des cannes de
remarqué la généralisation oui il faut
qu'on les mette c'est à dire que la loi
la loi désormais autorise mais des
caméras embarquées dans les véhicules
non pas pour surveiller les policiers
mais pour qu'ils regardent dehors et ce
qui remplacerait évidemment aussi les
lieux où il n'y a pas de caméra de
vidéoprojection dans les zones rurales
ou dans les endroits où il n'y a pas de
caméra vidéoprojection chez les pompiers
aussi ce qui nous aiderait aussi
fortement pour lutter contre les
attaques donc oui je suis très favorable
et on a prévu la généralisation des
caméras embarquées comme il existe dans
certaines positions anglo-saxonnes ou
d'ailleurs les vidéos sont à disposition
de la justice mais parfois sont mis en
ligne sur les sites des polices si vous
êtes sur la police de la police de
nouilles de Los Angeles tout semble-t-il
vous pouvez voir les images filmées
lorsqu'il y a des événements contestés
contestables par la population où j'y
suis très très favorable sur le maintien
de l'ordre de la tenue
vous avez raison il faudrait que tu
multiplions cela on le fait depuis des
gilets jaunes parce que c'était pas le
cas ce qui a bien marché si j'ose dire
pendant ces périodes c'est les tenues
ignifugées à chacun se rappelle du drame
de Viry-Châtillon où les policiers ont
été extrêmement brûlés dans leur chair
quasiment tout le monde c'est pas le cas
intégralement mais quasiment tout le
monde a tenu ifugé quand il y a des
émotures ce qui a évité à ce pauvre
policier qui d'ailleurs ce député je
crois est entier de ne pas mourir de son
cocktail Molotov qu'on a tous vu à la
télévision pendant les manifestations
grâce à des fichiers et pourtant il est
brûlé mais il n'est pas brûlé au point
d'avoir été très handicapé par cela ce
qui a permis aussi parce que les
cocktails Molotov étaient très présents
de protéger les policiers légendes de
leur de leurs blessure donc on a fait
les tenues figées on est en train de
faire les tenues de matière de l'ordre
mais ça coûte 20000 euros par unité et
donc on le fait avec les moyens que le
Parlement nous consent à votre bon cœur
messieurs dames puisque vous rentrez en
discussion budgétaire très bientôt sur
la question de la brogole j'y reviens
excusez-moi
moi Madame rogol ce qui est à ma
connaissance c'est que ce policier et ce
gendarme ce policier pardon ces deux
policiers le 38 et 40 ans ils étaient
expérimentés ils n'avaient aucun dossier
négatif à disposition du préfet de
police de moi-même aucun avertissement à
ma connaissance aucune difficulté
particulière de hiérarchie ils avaient
même été ancien militaire il était
décoré par sa hiérarchie sous d'autres
ministres que moi et donc moi je je n'ai
rien à reprocher à ce policier voilà
mais je n'ai rien à reprocher à ce
policier je n'ai rien à reprocher à la
vie de ces policiers jusqu'au moment où
il a commis ses actes qui aujourd'hui
lui permettent de répondre devant devant
la justice et encore une fois j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires à faire pour
Monsieur Morel aluci je terminerai par
là Monsieur le Député monsieur le
Président la doctrine d'intervention il
faudra faire un rétexte ce qui s'est
passé ce qui est certain c'est que
l'utilisation
du raid la Berry du GIGN voir des psigs
non seulement a permis de rétablir le
calme dans des conditions où chacun a vu
que les gens étaient à la fois très
violents et très jeunes ce qui est
évidemment un drame à chaque
intervention il y a à ma connaissance
moins de 15 enquête igpn et GIGN sur les
émeutes qui se sont passés il faut
toutes les prendre au sérieux la justice
va travailler mais sur 3800
interpellations et 4000 émeutes
statistiquement constatera que les
policiers gendarmes ont fait preuve dans
l'immense majorité des cas et devant
l'immense violence de ce qui s'est passé
la très grande sang-froid un très grand
professionnalisme incontestablement et
je pense qu'on peut tirer quelques
conclusions sur l'utilisation du raid du
GIGN de la Berry ou des PSIG en
administratif c'est-à-dire à la main du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des préfets
alors que c'est plutôt vous le savez
bien des unités d'élite qui sont là soit
pour le terrorisme soit pour la très
grande délinquance organisée soit des
unités judiciaires type Berry qui
agissent en PJ pour pouvoir voilà faire
des filatures interpeller des gens qui
font des go-fastes des choses
extrêmement graves et dont on voit que
leur présence à la fois par leur
matériel par leur formation et par le
respect qu'ils inspirent lorsqu'ils
arrivent sur un territoire comme cela ne
permettrait peut-être de mettre fin
définitivement à certains axes de
délinquance qui existe dans certains de
nos quartiers et qui ne sont réglés par
la police du quotidien si j'ose dire
avec des moyens qui sont pas à la
hauteur des gens très organisés que nous
avons en face de nous et vous m'avez
parlé de police proximité tout à l'heure
le défaut de la police nationale
gendarmerie nationale encore plus de la
police parce que c'est pas l'homme
délinquance c'est pas je sais qu'il y a
un débat depuis très longtemps sur la
police de proximité mais c'est pas
l'idée que on donne pas de consignes
pour dire vous faites pas de proximité
enfin tous les élus quels qu'ils soient
et notamment l'ancien maire que je suis
content quand les policiers sont à pied
pour voir les commerçants et discute
avec les gens du quartier le problème
c'est que c'est une police qui est très
une police d'intervention elle est
devenue plus intervention les attentats
les difficultés autour des
manifestations sporadiques et notamment
vous le savez bien des gilets jaunes la
lutte contre la drogue qui est une qui
touche tous les quartiers et vous savez
bien désormais des villages y compris
extrêmement petit et le nombre de
d'appels 17 qui a explosé les violences
intrafamiliales j'ai l'occasion de vous
dire c'était 450 000 interventions par
an ce qui n'existait pas il y a encore
10 ou 15 ans au moment où on pourrait
parler de ce discours surprise de
proximité et donc je crois que ce qui se
passe pour les policiers c'est que ils
sont beaucoup en intervention donc c'est
une police de plus en plus
d'interventions pour lutter contre tous
ces actes de délinquance et parce qu'ils
sont désormais les derniers à pouvoir
gérer ces difficultés et peut-être que
le temps qu'il passe à intervenir il ne
passe pas à être proche de la population
et en étant proche de la population il
s'agit pas de moi pense que serait une
erreur de distinguer de police parce que
c'est c'est la même qui fait les deux
vous le savez bien mais me semble-t-il
que l'augmentation des effectifs que
nous mettons en place répond à ça et il
faut assez dans un commissariat pour à
la fois intervenir et faire de la
proximité et c'est très bien que les
policiers fassent les deux tantôt la
proximité au sens je suis en contact
avec la population sans excuse
d'intervention et tantôt de
l'intervention parce que sinon
évidemment une sorte de schizophrénie
qui s'installe donc je pense que ça
vautour a un problème d'effectif
peut-être de temps horaire peut-être
d'utilisation peut-être de mutilation
des policiers des gendarmes mais
d'effectif c'est pas une question de
doctrine il y a pas un type au ministère
d'intérieur qui dit il faut pas faire de
proximité je le fasse je demande tous
les jours aux policiers simplement ils
vous disent quand vous êtes dans un
commissariat vous savez bien on a
aujourd'hui 50 appels 17 on a reçu il y
a deux points de vie la démocler il y a
trois dames qui sont fait taper dessus
par leur mari et puis il y a deux
forcenets et on a fait que
l'intervention tous les jours donc c'est
une question plus d'effectif me
semble-t-il et j'espère qu'on essaie de
le réparer que de doctrine même si on
pourrait évidemment en parler pendant
très longtemps
merci alors monsieur Gilles Legend
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'étais très sensible à la
distinction que vous opériez au début de
votre propos entre les émeutes que nous
avons connues et les opérations
traditionnelles avec beaucoup de
guillemets autour de traditionnels de
maintien de l'ordre il y a néanmoins un
certain nombre de phénomènes qui peuvent
affecter les les deux familles j'allais
dire c'est des urgences évidemment des
messageries cryptées des applications
telles que snapchat qui permet aux
manifestants dans certains cas aux
émeutiers toujours de se rendre discret
d'agir avec beaucoup d'agilité de
pouvoir bouger de façon très rapide et
se livrer évidemment à leurs méfaits
comme on l'a pu le constater cette
technique compensent souvent l'absence
d'organisation et de structure comme on
peut en avoir dans les manifestations
alors là pour le coup vraiment
traditionnels qui sont déclarés et qui
sont déclarés par des organisations
connues alors ma question est la
suivante est-ce qu'il existe est-ce que
vous avez maintenant
la faveur si je puis dire des événements
qui se sont produits un retour
d'expérience sur le rôle réel que joue
ces pratiques dans les manifestations
est-ce que nos services de renseignement
peuvent avoir et nos forces de l'ordre
peuvent en tirer un intérêt pour
éventuellement se réorganiser trouver
d'autres réponses évoluées et puis le
cas échéant est-ce que la loi locmique
nous avons adopté il y a peu permettra
aussi d'améliorer la réponse à ce type
d'enjeu et de défi je vous remercie
rouleau
le président monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur
l'équipe en destinés aux forces de
l'ordre la ville de Meaux a été impactée
comme bien d'autres communes de France
et comme l'ensemble du département par
des émeutes dans la nuit du 29 au 3
juillet un groupe d'individus d'une
centaine de personnes 97 très exactement
armée de barres de fer et projectile en
tout genre adorent a d'abord voulu s'en
prendre au commissariat de Meaux
repousser
et par les forces de police il est allé
plus loin dans un autre quartier où il a
incendié un bus une partie du centre
commercial de la verrière la Poste
l'unité de police municipale sans
compter les commerces payés vandalisés
le choc chez les commerçants et la
population était grande je me suis rendu
dans chacun de ces commerces et je suis
allée féliciter les jours suivants les
forces de l'ordre pour leur travail et
leur courage ayant permis d'éviter le
pire au cours de ma visite à la
gendarmerie de Meaux j'ai eu l'occasion
de voir les équipements que tu utilises
les gendarmes certains gilets par balles
arrêtent des balles de 9 mm d'autres non
certains casques les MSA G3 résistent à
des balles et des barres de fer d'autres
moins en réalité on m'explique dans
cette gendarmerie que les casques
efficaces pour ce genre d'émeutes quasi
insurrectionnel sont en nombre
insuffisant on dispose de deux par
unités si j'ai bien retenu ou deux pour
trois et l'on me fait remarquer surtout
qui ne sont pas individ attribué à
chacun de sorte qu'il faut les régler ce
qui fait perdre des secondes ou des
minutes précieuses en cas d'intervention
urgente vite vite je vais perdre des
secondes de même il n'a pas il n'y a pas
assez de tenue
ignifiée une inflammable alors que le
risque de recevoir des cocktails Molotov
et constant ma question est donc la
suivante de nos jours où les émeutiers
ne reculent rien et sont prêts à tirer à
balles réelles sur des policiers
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre si les gendarmes mobiles voir
les unités de police disposeront
madame Martin Étienne
monsieur le ministre je dois vous dire
j'ai le cœur lourd j'ai le cœur lourd
parce que le 30 juin dernier à
Mont-Saint-Martin un jeune homme de 26
ans a été touché à la tête par un tir de
Bing bag il s'appelle mn Bahou il est
agent de sécurité il rentrait du travail
en voiture monsieur le ministre et il
allait simplement chercher à manger avec
des amis à quelques kilomètres de chez
lui mais en une fraction de seconde sans
comprendre ni voir pourquoi et comment
il a reçu un tir de Bing bag dans la
tête un projectile envoyé par le Raid
sans sommation et par surprise
aujourd'hui il est toujours entre la vie
et la mort alors oui j'ai le cœur lourd
comme sa famille ses voisins et les
habitants de la commune qui nagent de sa
commune qui nage dans l'incompréhension
la colère et le désarroi
sa famille a porté à porter plainte et
un policier à tenter de leur expliquer
l'inexplicable il leur a dit qu'elle
mène se trouvait alors au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment monsieur le
ministre vous vous rendez compte de la
violence de ses propos vous dites
vouloir maintenir l'ordre en seulement
aux gens de rentrer chez eux et vous
appelez le raid pour être pour régler
les choses dans les petites communes
c'est quoi la suite pas de chance pour
les habitants qui rencontrent le raid en
bas de chez eux le maintien de l'ordre
n'est pas une affaire de chance c'est
une affaire de respect des droits
humains et de justice
votre réponse ultra sécuritaire ou
révolte qui traverse le pays depuis
maintenant quelques semaines et
largement inadapté et le tir contre
elle-même en études en est une preuve de
plus monsieur le ministre combien
faudra-t-il encore de victimes pour que
vous refondiez enfin la police de la
cave au grenier quand à gérez-vous comme
le recommande l'ONU contre les violences
racistes au sein de la police et enfin
que faisait le raid dans cette commune
merci
monsieur Yann muca
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre notre pays cela a été rappelé a
connu des émeutes particulièrement
graves ou les symboles de la République
ont été attaqués ou la République a été
attaquée sur le dévouement et le courage
nos forces de l'ordre le bilan humain et
matériel aurait pu être beaucoup plus
lourd nos forces de l'ordre je voudrais
rappeler on le soutient d'une immense
majorité des Français et les armements
les étirements parlant de extrême gauche
n'y changeront strictement rien je
voudrais le réaffirmer au nom du groupe
républicain notre plein orientier
soutien il y a ceci évidemment nos
pompiers mais également les élus locaux
qui ont été en première livrée également
salut les services de l'État et j'ai pu
constater dans mon département du
Territoire de Belfort la parfaite
coordination entre Monsieur le Préfet
les forces de l'ordre et la mairie de
Belfort pour lutter contre ses émeutes
qui commençait à se propager dans notre
ville mais ces émeutes ont également
montré qu'il y avait un manque de
matériel cela a été dit pour nos forces
de l'ordre et dans ce sens je me réjouis
que nous ayons pu adapter très largement
la locmi à l'automne dernier ces émeutes
ont également montré l'armement massif
existant dans certains quartiers ma
question est donc simple monsieur mise
intérieur que comptez-vous faire pour
lutter contre ce phénomène et
comptez-vous interdire prochainement la
vente de mortier qui ont été utilisés
par comme arme par destination dans de
nombreuses émeutes
madame Blandine brocard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre à mes chers collègues la
question de la gestion du refus
d'obtempérer et central dans nombre
d'affaires alors tragiquement parfois
comme dans le cas qui a été à l'origine
des récentes émeutes mais n'oublions pas
non plus de saluer également et bien
plus souvent l'action des forces de
l'ordre qui permet justement d'éviter de
nombreux drames qui auraient été commis
par des conducteurs sans permis ou sous
emprise d'alcool ou de stupéfiants alors
lors de votre récentes audition au Sénat
vous avez donné les chiffres suivants
monsieur le ministre en 2022 les forces
de l'ordre ont consigné 25800 refus
d'obtempérer et plus d'un sur 5 soit
5329 se déroule dans des circonstances
qui exposent directement autrui à un
risque de mort il semble dans les
échanges que j'ai régulièrement avec eux
que les policiers et gendarmes sont
souvent très peu enclins voire très
réticents à engager une poursuite à
jalonner comme ils disent craignant pour
la sécurité du délinquant routier comme
pour celle des forces de l'ordre et des
autres usagers de la route
comme vous le disiez en effet 20% des
cas de refus d'obtempérer exposent des
individus à des risques de blessures ou
de mort dans un rapport parlementaire
publié en 2021 sur les rodéo motorisées
des policiers et gendarmes auditionnés
soulignent que les modalités
d'intervention leur semblent souvent peu
clair leur faisant craindre un
engagement de leur responsabilité en cas
de poursuite d'un véhicule pourriez-vous
nous indiquer quelle doctrine les forces
de l'ordre sont censées suivre dans
cette situation de quels moyens
dispose-t-elle autre que l'usage de leur
arme pour stopper un véhicule et quid
des auteurs à l'occasion du déferment de
la locmi devant le Conseil
constitutionnel le dispositif visant
augmenter le contour des peines dans les
cadres refus d'obtempérer avaient été
censurés leur rayonnement du phénomène
ne devrait-il pas selon vous reposer sur
un renforcement des sanctions et à
l'instar des cas de rodéo urbain la
confiscation systématique du véhicule ne
devrions-nous pas en outre agir en amont
en renforçant par exemple les sanctions
envers les personnes qui permettent la
conduite sans permis par le prêt ou la
location de leur véhicule je vous
remercie madame Cécile
dans Monsieur le Ministre alors sur la
mort de Naël ce sont les vidéos qui
laissent penser que le policier n'a pas
respecté la loi de 2017 si on n'avait
pas eu les vidéos on n'aurait pas pu
dire s'il avait respecté ou non la loi
2017 en tout cas ça aurait été plus
difficile mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que ces vidéos elles ont une
puissance de révélation qui est
importante
d'autant plus importante au regard de
conclusion que l'on pourrait supposer
avoir été celle de l'IGPN
je suis pas dans un propos
discriminant par rapport à cette
institution simplement je pense que
c'est le moment de nous interroger
d'avoir une réflexion sur la question de
l'indépendance de l'IGPN ça fait un
moment qu'on en parle mais est-ce que
c'est pas à l'occasion de ce tragédie
qui nous faut
reconsidérer les organes de contrôle de
la police parce que elle est placée on
le sait sous le contrôle de la direction
générale de la police nationale donc
elle est en situation de devoir
contrôler les autorités qui l'encadrent
alors c'est vrai que des efforts ont été
faits que c'est un magistrat qui est à
la tête je crois de l'IGPN et que j'ai
pas de doute particulier mais vous savez
comment ça se passe la partialité
subjective ou objective elle est là à
raison de la façon dont s'inscrit
l'organe de contrôle dans l'institution
et sans vouloir aller jusque chez les BR
itanniques est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
engager une réflexion sur ce sujet et ma
deuxième question c'est sur la loi de
2017 que moi je n'avais pas voté
et qui comme vous l'avez très bien dit
n'a pas été mal appliqué simplement en
nous parle d'une circulaire de mars qui
poserait des problèmes parce qu'elle
dirait au-delà des termes de la loi
monsieur Paul Molac
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
monsieur le ministre
des échauffs fourrés à Lorient ont eu
lieu ils ont été relatés par les deux
journaux que sont le Ouest-France et le
Télégramme ou en fait une trentaine de
personnes cagoulées visage masqué se
revendiquant Patriotes ont finalement et
certains se disant commando marine sont
venus prêter ma forte aux policiers pour
contre les émeutiers sauf que évidemment
ils se sont aussi attaqués à des gens
qui ne faisaient que passer et ils ne se
sont pas contentés simplement des
immobiliser mais parfois tabasser et
donc c'est un mouvement qui est
effectivement m'inquiète parce que on a
eu dans l'histoire
relativement récente des partis
politiques qui avaient leur propre
milice qui maintenait l'ordre etc qui se
faisait un peu la guerre entre eux donc
moi ma question est simple je
souhaiterais tout simplement
que vous nous assuriez d'abord que ces
choses là ne vont pas se multiplier
parce que effectivement ça pourrait
poser problème tandis que sont de gens
qui visiblement ont accès à des armes
également donc c'est même si les
utilisaient pas là et la deuxième chose
bon moi je pense que le maintien de
l'ordre doit être assuré par des
fonctionnaires à fermentés et qui ont
reçu une formation pour ça donc voilà
donc mon inquiétude
madame Émilie Chandler
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher
coach tout d'abord à vous remercier de
prendre le temps de répondre à nos
questions monsieur le ministre ces
dernières semaines les forces de l'ordre
et de secours ont été particulièrement
mobilisés pour répondre aux épisodes de
violence que notre pays a connu je tiens
à saluer leur travail leur disponibilité
leur réactivité ma circonscription a
connu plusieurs incidents avec des élus
locaux qui ont été agressés des
bâtiments comme le la mairie de Persan
et le CCAS et le poste de police
municipale qui ont été incendies et
détruits si les dégâts sont importants
je tiens à saluer l'action de votre
ministère qui a libéré des moyens
conséquents supplémentaires pour
maintenir l'ordre j'ai bien entendu nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale qui
ont été plus promptes à demander le
désarmement de la police qui a condamné
les violences des émeutiers lorsque l'on
est élu de la République il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause le travail de
nos forces de l'ordre notre mandat est
d'aider nos concitoyens votant des lois
dans l'intérêt de tous et non considérer
que l'on peut s'affranchir quand on le
souhaite de la loi
j'ai aussi entendu d'autres demandez
l'instauration de l'état d'urgence je
comprends bien que nos collègues soient
enclins à reproduire ce qu'ils ont déjà
connu mais le reflux de violence prouve
qu'il n'est nul besoin de recourir un
régime d'exception pour répondre à
certaines situations notre assemblée est
plus particulièrement notre majorité a
toujours travaillé à donner les outils
adaptés aux forces de l'ordre pour
réaliser leur mission ainsi que nous
avons pu le constater les violences ont
diminuées ces derniers jours on aurait
pu craindre en effet un retour de
violence notamment avec l'intervention
de certains groupes qui ont appelé à se
mobiliser ma question sera simple
monsieur le ministre est-ce que certains
mouvements tenté de guider les violences
et comment votre ministère a-t-il
répondu aux appels à la convergence des
luttes de ces mouvements je vous
remercie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite vous interroger sur
le trafic de stupéfiants qui touche
particulièrement ma ville de Marseille
Nord notamment dans ma circonscription
mais aussi de plus en plus toute notre
pays aujourd'hui en France le trafic de
stupéfiant et le moteur essentiel de
l'activité CRIM il crée des enclaves de
non-droits formalisés par des mini
frontières des barrages des guerres des
règlements de comptes et toujours plus
de la sécurité de dégradation pour les
gens qui le subissent l'économie
parallèle qui s'y développe à coups de
blanchiment et de trafic en tout genre
créé de facto et ne voient parallèles
qui s'opposent à celle de la République
française et quand j'ai décidé de
l'homme je peux dire que le trafic de
stupéfiant encore graine de notre pays
vous avez beau donner du doliprane pour
freiner cette gangrène j'ai rien y fait
il y a trois ans en 2020 alors que vous
deveniez ministre de l'Intérieur vous
aviez affirmé que les trafiquants de
drogue allaient arrêter de dormir en
effet je vous le confirme vous aviez
raison ils dorment peu en réalité il
travaille trop vous dites pilonner les
supermarchés de la drogue si ce
pilonnage était efficace le prix des
stupides des stupéfiants devrait monter
ils sont plus rares ils sont plus chers
c'est la loi de l'offre et de la demande
or c'est le contraire qui se produit
mais revenons sur les émeutes j'étais
sur le terrain lors de la deuxième nuit
d'émeutes et je peux vous dire que j'ai
été prévenu par des habitants de la cité
voisine que des livraisons de mortier
était en distribution ou pour les aux
jeunes de la cité de ma circonscription
et que le mot d'ordre était d'attraper
le comité d'attaquer le commissariat ce
qui m'a permis de donner l'alerte aux
autorités ici notre grâce à l'arrivée
des renforts de la mairie que le
commissariat n'a pas été attaqué
j'aimerais comprendre pourquoi le
commissariat était si peu protégé de
policiers de garde alors que certains
policiers pouvaient pourtant volontaire
volontaire était en congé manifester
leur surprise de ne pas avoir été
appelés en protection du commissariat
merci
et enfin Monsieur Thomas
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question portera sur l'unité
crs8 déployer de manière très violente
lors des révoltes urbaines mais aussi
lors de la Marche Blanche organisée pour
la mémoire de Naël à Nanterre cette
brigade a été créée en 2021 pour
intervenir selon des méthodes plus
répressives et avec un équipement plus
léger lui permettant d'aller davantage
au contact deux rapports confidentiels
révélés par la presse font état de
dysfonctionnement récurrent ou cette
brigade vont être notamment
l'affectation de jeunes policiers
incapable de faire du maintien de
l'ordre car encore une expérimenté dans
l'un de ces rapports le commandant
ancien membre de la Marine nationale
vous a demandé de solliciter cette
brigade uniquement lors des situations
dégradées ou de haute intensité sans
quoi ces hommes éprouveraient je cite
une frustration en clair il demande
d'aller au contact vous avez et cela
interroge favorablement répondu à cette
demande on comprend bien que la CS la
crs8 qui est en quelque sorte est votre
brave m pour reprendre les propos d'un
préfet si tu es un Mediapart est
intervenu dans les quartiers marseillais
après les fusillad meurtrières d'avril à
Mayotte lors de l'opération en
qualifiable de wambushu avant d'être
lors des rêveurs des révoltes urbaines
suite au meurtres de Noël alors que vous
avez annoncé la création d'ici 2024 de 4
nouvelles compagnies sur le modèle de la
crs8 basé notamment à Marseille et à
Nantes les alertes se multiplient sur
cette unité violente un préfet ayant eu
la crs8 sur son territoire explique que
c'est je cite là aussi une compagnie
qu'il faut tenir Rennes courtes car elle
peut être assez incontrôlable un gradé
présent à Mayotte ou des membres de la
CRS suite ont tiré à 12 reprises à
balles réelles rappelle comme bon
maintien de l'ordre et celui qui se
passe bien et déplore les réponses
répressives à porter qui ne résolvent
pas le fond du problème
arènes ce sont plusieurs membres de la
CRS 8 là aussi qui sont qui sont
distingués par la violence et sont
désormais visés par une enquête mise en
jeu par un lance-grenade carte de presse
arrachée plaquage ventrale les images
sont aussi des rentes monsieur le
ministre vous avez eu sûrement
connaissance de ces deux rapports vous
étiez destinataires vous n'ignorez pas
les dérives de la CRS 8 alors pourquoi
l'avoir mobilisé lors de ces révoltes
urbaines et pourquoi voulez-vous
éteindre ce modèle alors qu'on sait
qu'il est dangereux
avant de donner la parole aussi ministre
j'informe la commission mais qu'il avait
été déjà par des déclarations que nous
procéderons à la rentrée à une
évaluation de la loi 2017 dans le cadre
d'une émission de la formation et je
l'ai déjà annoncé mais au moins comme ça
toute la Commission en est informé
merci monsieur le Président alors pour
répondre au président de gens sur les
messageries écrites je pense qu'il faut
distinguer plusieurs choses
faut distinguer ce qui relève des
réseaux sociaux qui par ailleurs ou une
fonction messagerie sur Instagram sur
Twitter sur Facebook des messageries
cryptées qui sont utilisés parce que
messagerie cryptée ce cas de WhatsApp ou
de signal au Télégramme mais qui n'est
pas en soi un réseau social au sens où
est-ce que je veux dire il ne rend pas
public un certain nombre de choses ou
dans des conditions extrêmement
restreintes des messageries cryptées
qu'utilisent une organisation criminelle
comme téléphone parallèle à la ligne
téléphonique classique vous avez vu que
les policiers dans l'affaire Sky OCC et
les gendarmes dans la selle dans la
salle ancrocs ont mis à jour de
véritables réseaux de messagerie
cryptées avec des téléphones cryptés
mais qui sont organisés pour être des
circuits parallèles à ces messageries
classiques qui utilisent votre téléphone
classique et puis quatrièmement ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des talkie walkie ou
des radios qui sont un système de son
classique type CB type de Radio
Classique on utilise pour être en
parallèle de tout ce qui ressemble à un
téléphone pour pouvoir organiser ses
méfaits je pense que c'est pas la même
réponse technique et évidemment ça pose
des questions juridiques des coupes
administratives ou judiciaire et
d'action sur ce point ce qui est certain
monsieur le Président c'est que
les écoutes téléphoniques classiques qui
est
qui est très largement utilisé par les
services judiciaires toujours sur
l'autorité magistrat donc ou en
administratif après 4 signatures vous le
savez bien dont celle de celui que vous
additionnez chaque année me semble-t-il
que le président de la Commission
nationale des écoutes téléphoniques et
des techniques dites de renseignements
ne rapporte plus grand chose ces écoutes
téléphoniques classiques parce que tout
le monde utilise ces messageries dites
cryptées quel que soit ce modèle et
notamment les deux premiers parce que
ils sont plus plus facile plus aisés
plus modernes et puis deux parce que ils
ont la réputation vrai ou fausse d'être
sécurisé bon et si des gens qui n'ont
rien à se reprocher utilisent ces
messagers cryptés je pense que c'est le
cas me semble-t-il de 100% ou quasiment
des parlementaires qui sont par exemple
ici et personne n'a rien à se reprocher
ici bien évidemment et les utilisent
alors imaginez que ce genre de choses à
se reprocher il les utilise d'autant
plus surtout que la plupart des
solutions sont gratuites
alors
quelle est la solution est-ce que
technologiquement nous pouvons écouter
ou regarder des messages qui relèvent
d'une de ces quatre catégories la
réponse est oui
nous avons les moyens et la France est
un grand pays avec des grosses de
renseignements nous avons les moyens de
pouvoir
regarder écouter des messages sur
relèvent de ces messagers des cryptés
avec notamment ce qu'on appelle la
captation dite à distance c'est-à-dire
que dans une écoute téléphonique
classique vous écoutez l'onde la radio
le message entre deux téléphones dans
une écoute téléphonique moderne
messagerie gryptée par exemple sur
WhatsApp sur signal sur télégram et à ce
titre il n'y a pas de messager plus
crypté que les autres nous ayons nous
regardons le téléphone vous voyez ce que
je veux dire qui peut soit agir comme un
micro mais vous avez une discussion me
semble-t-il le garde des sauts très
intéressant de cette question ces
derniers jours soit en filmant le
téléphone et ce n'est pas la messagerie
que l'on regarde c'est le téléphone que
l'on regarde de qu'on écoute qui nous
permet d'avoir ces renseignements est-ce
que juridiquement vous nous autorisez à
le faire la réponse est oui en
terrorisme
et la réponse est oui en criminalité
organisée le très grand banditisme
est-ce que vous utilisez vous autorisez
à le faire pour la délinquance regardez
de droit commun de enfin je mets des
guillemets petit trafic de drogue un
meurtre qui n'a pas l'air à un autre de
crime organisé donc des choses qui sont
très difficiles pour le pour le pacte
républicain mais qui ne relève pas de la
définition juridique vous autorisez pas
le faire donc moi je ne peux pas en
administratif pour ce qui me concerne ou
les magistrats en judiciaire pour ce qui
les concerne regardez ce qui se passe
sur Facebook sur telegram sur Twitter
sur snapchat sur tout ce que vous voulez
si vous n'êtes pas en terrorisme et si
vous n'êtes pas au criminalité organisé
et donc dans ces cas-là même vous
donneriez des éléments précis je ne
pourrais pas le faire parce que on
m'autoriserait pas à le faire
alors ceci étant dit faut-il faire
évaluer évoluer la loi
moi personnellement je suis favorable
dans des conditions évidemment
d'encadrement et de respect de liberté
privée mais c'est quoi la messagers
équipées si c'était que la modernisation
de l'appel téléphonique d'hier ou
d'avant-hier que nous pouvons utiliser
nous pouvons écouter téléphoniquement
déjà en administratif
pour des choses qui ne relèvent pas du
terrorisme et du grand banditisme donc
nous le faisons évidemment notamment
pour les finalités que le président de
la délégation au renseignement à
connaître et dont je rencontre en tant
que gouvernement pour savoir est-ce
qu'on a le droit d'utiliser ces
techniques pour cela et donc évidemment
tout cela est contrôlé et bien sûr le
gouvernement est très contenté sur cela
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faudra qu'on
se pose cette question alors il y a
trois types de possibilités soit vous
nous autorisez à le faire
ça pose des questions de liberté
publique très importante qui relèvent
sans doute de l'analy discussion qui a
eu autour des écoss téléphoniques hier
soit en administratif sans judiciaire
soit 2 mais pour gérer des
manifestations c'était pas en judiciaire
les deux premiers jours c'était au moins
un administratif vous le constaterez
avec moi soit vous nous dites il faut
que vous ayez ou alors qu'on vous donne
la possibilité d'avoir des failles dans
le système des entreprises qui gèrent
WhatsApp signal telegram et donc il y
aurait une sorte d'obligation à ce que
les services de protection du pays dans
des conditions qu'il faut évidemment
encadrer puissent obtenir de WhatsApp de
signal de télégramme sous peine de sinon
une diffusent pas en France un accès
lorsque nous jugeons quelqu'un donc on
n'écoute pas ce que vous dites votre
téléphone on a une autorisation pour
entrer dans le système qui permet de
voir ce qui se passe pour tel ou telle
personne ou alors on part du principe
que la liberté et la sécurité c'est un
équilibre difficile et qu'on accepte
parfois que les services vis à
l'intérieur de soient pas si efficaces
que demander par la population parce que
on ne veut pas rentrer dans une société
où le médecin intérieur a les moyens de
surveillance et dans ces cas là on
accepte qu'il y ait des émeutes on
accepte qu'il y a des drames parce que
simplement on préfère la liberté
vous voyez ce que je veux dire par
rapport à l'action répressive ou de
surveillance ce qui est certain c'est
que la réponse est sans doute un peu
dans les trois et que il faut que vous
compreniez bien que le ministère de
l'Intérieur contrairement à ce que j'ai
pu entendre lire à la télévision j'ai
même vu des parlementaires du
rassemblement national le dire mais ce
ne sont pas présent ici et c'est dommage
dire que fait le mise à l'intérieur il
devrait regarder snapchat et regarder
Facebook et regarder télégramme mais
c'est pas la loi moi j'applique la loi
de la République et les policiers
gendarmes ils avaient quand même la
République on ne peut pas regarder
snapchat on peut le faire soit en source
ouverte
soit lorsque des personnes sont déjà
sous techniques de renseignement et qui
contribuent répondrai à la question à je
sais pas voilà quoi la conjonction des
luttes comme vous les avez appelé ça
nous est arrivé ou alors judiciaire on a
des messages on a des personnes et on
demande qu'on nous autorise et en
judiciarise ce que fait farose
poursuivre cette personne mais on a
forcément un temps beaucoup plus long
donc évidemment un rôle d'un sujet
extrêmement essentiel dans ce qui s'est
passé entre Céline par exemple il y a eu
à la fois les messages écrits classiques
mais il y a eu aussi ce qu'on appelle
les radios il y a un système de radio
parallèle voilà ça c'est une autre façon
évidemment de regarder les choses alors
il y a plein de moyens technologiques
pour pouvoir surveiller tout ça les
émissaires enfin vous avez sans doute eu
l'occasion discuter avec ça avec des
chefs des services de renseignement donc
on a les moyens technologiques de le
faire je veux juste souligner que dans
le cas de Sky ou notre chat nous avons
pu et c'est un très intéressant et si
vous n'avez pas fait je vous donne enfin
vous pourriez auditionner les enquêteurs
avec Europole et Interpol qui ont réussi
à ça à arrêter ça on a on a pu regarder
des vidéos il se passait des vidéos en
direct d’assassinat pour montrer à leur
commanditaire qu'ils avaient fait leur
assassinat donc on a pu arrêter des gens
des équipes de tueurs notamment dans le
port du Havre notamment dans le port de
Marseille qui allait passer à d'autres
interpellations bien évidemment on a pu
aussi récupérer beaucoup d'images
pédocrinels parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
viol en direct qui se font aussi par
l'intermédiaire malheureusement de ces
outils et donc ce qui est certain c'est
quand on arrive à démanteler un système
parallèle que nous ne connaissons pas et
que nous démonstons grâce au travail de
la police et de gendarmerie ne serait-ce
qu'en saisissant tout simplement les
téléphones qui n'existent officiellement
pas nous obtenons d'énormes résultats
dans les contre la drogue des normes
résultats dans la lutte contre la
criminalité c'est un équilibre entre
sécurité liberté qui est vieux comme la
commission des lois ce président
sûrement écoutez madame la députée
j'entends mais ce qui s'est passé à
Meaux c'est passé un peu partout en
France j'étais en contact direct avec
Monsieur le Maire de mots que je salue
d'ailleurs Jean-François Copé qui m'a
demandé une unité de CRS qui vous avez
vu est arrivé dès le lendemain lui-même
était surpris il me semble-t-il parce
que mon n'est pas une ville qui connaît
une délinquance particulière dans les
émeutes par le travail que que qu'a fait
le maire et son équipe municipale bien
évidemment et après évidemment une
question de matériel madame la députée
mais bon on a déjà l'occasion d'en
parler vous savez des émeutes enfin moi
je veux bien qu'on en discute
évidemment c'est important la dernière
émeutes importantes c'est 2005
de ce de cette catégorie tous les 18-20
ans bon alors c'est à la fois important
parce que c'est traumatique il faut mais
en même temps relativiser un tout petit
peu hameau il se passe pas toutes les
semaines des choses qui consiste qui
considéraient qu'il faudrait équiper
contre des tirs de kalachnikov
l'intégralité des policiers et des
gendarmes bon donc il y a un travail à
faire d'amélioration je constate
qu'aucun policier gendarme avec vous
n'ont été victimes de tirs mortels ou
blessant à deux exceptions près à ma
connaissance qui est ce policier de
Nîmes qui a eu une balle de 9 mm dans
son gilet barbal il était protégé par
son gilet barbal donc l'administration
n'a pas fait si mal son travail et des
policiers à Lyon qui ont été tirés me
semble-t-il à chevrotine ce qui est
évidemment tout à fait condamnable mais
qui n'ont pas entraîné leur mort fort
heureusement il n'y a pas eu de tirs de
kalachnikov contre les forces de l'ordre
peut-être qu'elle se prochain drame
qu'on aura je dis pas mais je constate
que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas le cas par
ce qui a eu contre les policiers c'est
des mortiers des cocktails Molotov et
des coûts et blessures extrêmement
graves je pense assez policiers de
Marseille qui ont été modestés à terre
dans chacun et d'ailleurs dans les de
les auteurs contre ces PC ont été
interpellés voilà c'est c'est les
victimes de pour l'instant des armes
utilisées ne sont pas des armes qui
manifestants sont utilisées sur des
règlements de compte par exemple sur les
points deal ça arrivera peut-être un
jour il veut vraiment se s'y préparer on
vous le disant je ne nie pas mais je
constate que le matériel est mais si si
ou là il a pu avoir une exception le
matériel présent est plus important de
meilleure qualité que il était le cas il
y a trois quatre ans que je ferai une
mise à l'intérieur et j'ai parlé des
vêtements ignifugés et c'est évidemment
le cas j'aurais pas dû je crois à tout à
l'heure à Monsieur député sur le
matériel de matière sur le raid et ce
qui s'est passé dans la France d'abord
je veux évidemment dire que je me suis
qui lutte contre la mort puisque à ma
connaissance il est toujours dans le
coma en Belgique si mes informations
sont bonnes évidemment c'est un drame et
je veux apporter à lui-même et bien sûr
à sa famille
tout le monde tout le monde tout le
monde tout mon respect tout mon soutien
et toute la lumière doit être faite et
vous savez que l'Inspection Générale
paysanielle décision judiciaire avec une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
immédiatement bien sûr alors vous me
disiez un commentaire sur cette enquête
judiciaire mais vous me disiez madame et
sur le rôle ce monsieur je ne sais pas
je veux vraiment encore une fois je veux
voir des mots extrêmement forts pour le
soutenir l'UEFA et sa famille vous êtes
que faisait le raid dans cette commune
bon vous savez puisque je crois que vous
êtes élu ce territoire mais mais il y a
eu la veille un cabinet médical qui
était incendié dans cette cité il y a eu
un centre pour autiste et pour enfant
autiste qui a été attaqué incendié dans
cette cité et il y a eu des véhicules
qui ont été brûlés et qu'à la demande
des élus il y a eu unité d'intervention
comme partout sur le territoire national
donc qu'on ne fasse pas croire non plus
à la commission qui ne s'est rien passé
qu'on aurait le raid pour le plaisir
d'envoyer une brigade d'intervention
quand on attaque un centre pour autiste
avec des jeunes enfants autistes à
l'intérieur et un centre médical voilà
je veux dire qu'il y a une justification
que directeur départemental de la police
a entendu la demande des élus et a
demandé le reste qu'on lui a évidemment
accorder comme partout sur le territoire
national et là c'est le reste ça aurait
pu être le GIGN ça aurait pu être la
Berry aurait pu être le PSIG pour plein
de raisons il y a une répartition
géographique dans votre dans votre
territoire ça ne veut pas dire Madame
que je couvre tout ce qui se serait
passé dans des conditions qui ont
entraîné en tout cas le drame pour ce
monsieur mais je ne connais pas les
circonstances exactes de ce qui s'est
passé je veux apporter mon soutien à sa
famille mais je crois que l'utilisation
des brigades d'intervention telles que
je l'avais défini était justifié dans la
mesure où dans ce quartier très précis
il y a eu la veille des atteintes
extrêmement fortes que ne voulait pas
revivre ce quartier pour Monsieur
Boucard vous évoquez les mortiers vous
avez raison alors les mortiers je pense
qu'il faut qu'on en tire des conclusions
assez définitives désormais
quel est le problème le problème c'est
que cette quelque chose qui n'est pas
une impardination et qui le devient donc
il s'agit pas d'interdire les feux
d'artifice je pense que chacun
mais c'est qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'on puisse dire que les feux
d'artifice qui tournent chacun le sait
c'est quelque chose à la fois de beau
mais de dangereux doit être utilisé par
des professionnels donc moi je serai
assez d'avis je mets ce message à
sagacité de la commission des lois de
faire ce que nous faisons parfois dans
certains produits de pharmacie
c'est à dire que seul certains commerces
peut le vendre n'est pas tous la plupart
des ventes que vous savez sont faites
soit sur Internet soit la frontière mais
aussi elles sont faites dans des bazars
dans des
commerces des shops de d'occasion et en
fait c'est bien que c'est une revente ou
une revente et dans toutes les saisies
qu'on a faites on l'a souvent fait dans
des magasins qui ne devaient pas les
vendre normalement bon mais c'est pas
interdit en soi de le faire mais
cette c'est ce feu d'artifice c'est
mortier était ainsi utilisés il y a eu
aussi beaucoup de coopérations
internationales parce qu'ils sont
souvent produits en Pologne et en
République tchèque et notamment il y a
une très belle opération qui a été faite
par la police en lien avec les douanes
d'un camion qui a été arrêté en
Allemagne avec une tonne de mortier qui
était à livrer sans doute d'ailleurs pas
très loin de votre de votre territoire
donc moi je serai d'avis que nous
utilisions la même réglementation de la
production à la destruction de ce type
de feu d'artifice et de mortier que on
mette à chaque fois un numéro un
signalement un suivi comme on le fait
pour les médicaments par exemple qui de
la production à la destruction de ces
pharmaciens la Poste pharmacien tout
cela est suivi on sait que le produit
est supprimé et quel est le tracé exact
qu'on autorise que certains commerces à
le vendre et qu'on le vende qu'à des
gens qui ont des cartes professionnelles
ou qui ont une habilitation à le faire
et par ailleurs qu'on soit extrêmement
ferme et pourquoi pas renforcer à
certains nombre de sanctions pour ceux
qui vendent illégalement sur Internet et
par ailleurs je prendrai une initiative
avec mes collègues européens mon
prochain conseil des ministres de
l'Intérieur européen alors ça aurait dû
être jeudi mais vous avez vu que je ne
suis pas sûr d'être ministre de
l'Intérieur encore jeudi donc on va
attendre le prochain conseil mise à
l'intérieur
ce que je vois qu'avec ce type me
regarde
je veux dire je veux dire enfin il n'est
pas le seul il n'est pas le seul il
n'est pas le seul c'est du travail
mais c'est un très très très honorant de
l'être ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pense qu'il faut qu'on travaille
tous les pays européens parce que ce qui
s'est passé je prends l'exemple de ma
propre circonscription la ville de
Mouscron en Belgique heureusement que je
connais la bourse qui a interdit la
vente parce qu'on lui a demandé mais il
y a beaucoup de communes qui font
d'ailleurs qu'ils n'ont pas faites donc
je pense qu'un il y a un truc à faire et
notamment parce que il y a des Français
qui vendent aussi du côté allemand du
côté belge du côté italien ou du côté
espagnol quand ce sont eux qui
connaissent des émeutes ou des
difficultés donc je pense qu'il y a une
réglementation à avoir je suis pas sûr
qu'il faille vache pardon qui faille
beaucoup durcir les sanctions sauf
peut-être sur internet en revanche il y
a un réglementé cette profession et je
peux comprendre que les artificiers se
sont choqués lorsqu'on les confond avec
les émeutiers mais manifestement
n'importe qui ne peut pas utiliser des
mortiers pour répondre à votre question
madame brocard vous évoquez des refus de
tempérer moi j'ai quelques chiffres à
vous donner police et gendarmerie
confondus pour quelque chose soit bien
clair mais vous aurez ça dans
l'évaluation j'imagine que vous
conduirez en 2017 et le
9386 policiers et gendarmes blessés en
mission dans le cadre des refus
d'obtempérer
et en 2022 il y en a eu 9268 c'est à
dire que il y a à peu près chaque année
le même nombre de refus d'obtempérer qui
Blaise des policiers des gendarmes on
parle bien de quasiment mesdames
messieurs 10000 policiers et gendarmes
blessés chaque année d'une manière ou
d'une autre pas toujours mortelle forte
heureusement mais c'est à dire qu'on a
affaire à des choses extrêmement
violentes qui soient des quads des motos
évidemment des voitures l'usage alors
qu'il y a à peu près 10 000 personnes
baissées et si je regarde les tirs
l'usage de l'arme opérationnel police et
gendarmerie tout confondus c'était 429
tirs
davantage de tirs y compris sur le tir
en mouvement et je regarde police et
gendarmerie c'est les mêmes tendances à
ce titre je voudrais ainsi non pas
corriger mais compléter ce qui vous a pu
être dit ici il y a eu 200 de tirs pour
la police nationale en mouvement 53 pour
la gendarmerie en 2022 c'est 138 tirs
pour la police nationale mouvement et 30
pour la gendarmerie refus par le
conducteur d'un véhicule de tempérer une
sommation de s'arrêter exposant
directement
autrui à risque de mort aux infirmités
c'est-à-dire pour le policier ou pour
quelqu'un qui passe parce que ça arrive
évidemment on est 4246 en 2017
4905 en 2022 donc ça a même tendance à
augmenter et c'est vrai dans les cas
précis alors il est tout à fait vrai que
dans l'année 2022 on a déjà l'occasion
de le dire il y a eu plus de morts de la
part de ses tirs alors que moi de tirs
et c'est une année qu'il faudra regarder
dans votre évaluation je pense que c'est
assez intéressant de le faire qui est à
statistique par rapport à 2017 puisque
en 2021 c'était 4
en 2020 c'était deux donc c'est pas la
loi de 2017 ce qu'il y a débloqué les
policiers les gendarmes ils ont pas
fondamentalement changé leur formation
leur sortir donc il faille évaluer très
bien mais moi je veux redire que
ce n'est pas un permis de tuer comme
d'ailleurs la très bien dénoncé Bernard
Cazeneuve son indépendance de l'IGPN et
GIGN bon c'est un lieu débat pendant le
peut-être pas alourdir les propos madame
la député ce que je constate avec vous
Madame c'est que
pour enquêter il faut des enquêteurs les
enquêteurs ils sont où dans la police en
gendarmerie que fait le magistrat le
magistrat il choisit le service qu'il
souhaite pour enquêter parfois il
choisit des gendarmes pour enquêter sur
des policiers parfois je choisis des
policiers pour enquêter sur des
gendarmes parfois il choisit les GPN
parfois il choisit un autre service sa
police judiciaire par exemple donc
d'abord il n'y a pas d'obligation pour
l'IGP de GIGN d'enquêter dès qu'il y
aurait ce qu'on appellerait une bavure
il y a un service spécialisé mais il y a
d'autres services qui peuvent le faire
le magistrat est libre de le faire
deuxièmement madame vous faites semblant
de voir que l'IGP de GIGN ce n'est que
un service qui contrôle les autres en
judiciaire mais c'est pas vrai c'est une
direction de notre administration qui
comme toute inspection l'inspection
générale des finances toutes les
inspections qui existent et sous
l'autorité du ministreur et qui agit
soit en administratif et c'est normal
qu'en administratif soit quand même les
directeurs que je nomme qui est qui est
malus ce que je fais sinon pardon mais
ça devient très compliqué de d'être
ministre dans ce dans le gouvernement et
dans ce pays et par ailleurs ce sont pas
les mêmes qui eux en procédure d'enquête
agissent l'autorité des magistrats donc
si vous voulez les rendre indépendants
il faudrait au moins avouer le
distinguer ce qui relève de l'évaluation
interne du de l'administratif et de s'y
relève du judiciaire mais vous allez
encore créer des enquêteurs spécialisés
mais en tout cas il faut distinguer les
choses et puis troisièmement madame la
députée il faut bien voir que ce que
fait l'IGPN et aujourd'hui ça n'a rien à
voir ce que faisait j'ai fait des GG
encore 10-15 ou 20 ans d'abord c'est
jamais agréable pour un policier pour un
gendarme d'aller comme ils disent voir
les boeufs carottes ils sont mis en
garde à vue ça se passe pas très bien
toujours ils se sentent extrêmement
vexé d'être contrôlé par leur propre
collègue ils sont souvent pas très bien
vu de leurs autres collègues croisaient
pas croyait pas qu'il y a une communauté
de gens qui se réunissent à la cantine
et qu'ils échangent entre services c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça fonctionne
bon et ceux qui sont Ali GPN ils tombent
pas dans les commissariats après il se
spécialise voilà
mais je publie désormais les rapports du
GPN je j'oblige des directeurs généraux
à expliquer pourquoi il suit vous ne
suivent pas ces propositions et il
m'arrive de réformer et toujours dans le
sens toujours dans le sens de la gravité
les propositions faites par les GPS GIGN
donc voilà on peut en parler à l'envie
il y a pas de il y a pas de sujet je
rappelle que la Défenseur des droits
c'est dire que les tribunaux peuvent se
saisir et que nous avons je crois
beaucoup discuté de ça dans le niveau de
la sécurité sur la question de Monsieur
Molac sur les militaires du de l'Orient
un certain Patou c'est quelques-uns bon
qui ce serait mobilisé écoutez moi je
crois qu'un effet de service de
renseignement que j'ai eu les choses
sont vraies il y aurait eu des
militaires qui pour des raisons que je
ne comprends pas bien aurait je mets des
guillemets prêter ma forte au seuil de
sécurité sans aucune espèce évidemment
de loi et de règlement qui le permet
j'ai saisi le ministre des armées qui a
demandé dans le cadre de la DSD qui va
donc voilà vous savez bien regarder ce
qui se passe
une enquête est par ailleurs ouverte et
les choses sont particulièrement
surveillées nous avons eu dans le
sud-ouest de la France je ne sais plus
devant vous si c'est casse ou
Carcassonne enfin c'est une ville de
garnison qui a connu à peu près les
mêmes choses dans des circonstances moi
importantes c'était pas Castres monsieur
député bon bah ça devait être
Carcassonne et donc on a eu ces deux
félins à ma connaissance
il y a eu aussi des groupes
d'ultra-droites à Angers et
Lyon il y a des manifestations mais à ma
connaissance il y a pas eu de milice
alors quand j'ai il y en a manifestement
eu mais voilà d'autres enquêtes ont été
ouvertes des personnes ont d'ailleurs
été interpellées je vais le dire ici
donc oui c'est tout à fait condamnable
non c'est absolument pas acceptable et
oui on doit pas référence surveiller ses
profils je me permets de dire monsieur
député que le jour où la police au
jardin il n'a pas les moyens de se
respecter dans le grand public il faudra
pas s'étonner que des gens essaient de
s'injustice eux-mêmes qu'il s'agisse
malheureusement de gens qui pourraient
avoir accès à des armes ou du buraliste
qui en a marre de se faire voler comme
je l'ai vu à Reims pour la cinquième
fois dans l'année et qui a décidé
d'attendre tout le monde parce qu'il est
chasseurs avec son fusil et qu'il a et
qu'il a un certain âge donc je pense que
la bonne si on va éviter tout ça je sais
que vous êtes en républicain et vous
avez être conscient c'est la police
républicaine de le faire parce que dès
qu'il montre dès qu'on montre de la
faiblesse évidemment les gens se font
justice eux-mêmes même Chandler
évoque la question de de finalement des
mouvements qui auraient profité ou pas
de ces violences il y a eu une tentative
elle a réussi dans un endroit à Toulouse
dans le quartier du Mirail ou l'ultra
gauche a fait des actions en commun avec
les émeutiers c'est à ma connaissance le
seul endroit où cela a fonctionné
partout ailleurs
il est même arrivé que des gens du train
gauche se fassent très mal recevoir par
les émeutiers
et partout ailleurs lorsque des
manifestations dites contre les
violences policières qui ont été tenues
et qu'on essaie de faire une sorte de
conjonction d'élite ça a été le cas sur
les Champs-Élysées à Paris c'est le cas
dans plusieurs villes notamment à Lyon
et c'était le cas encore une fois à
Marseille à Toulouse ça n'a pas tenu et
ça n'a pas marché et oui les services de
renseignement notamment territoriaux les
notes sont à disposition de monsieur le
Président on documenté ça donc il n'y a
pas eu de conjonction des luttes
ponctuellement ça a marché que au Mirail
mais il y a une tentative effectivement
de conjonction sur
la question de la crs8 posée par
Monsieur porte bon moi d'abord je
n'utilise pas le mot reine courte pour
parler d'hommes et de femmes je suis
respectueux c'est pas des animaux ce
sont des policiers non non mais je voilà
je vous le dis je pense qu'il faut
respecter tout le monde je vous
encourage à passer une journée avec la
serre la suite
voilà le Sénator du Rhin qui je crois
fait partie de la nupes a fait une
expérience tout à fait intéressante
alors qu'il de soutient pas le
gouvernement je crois que c'est assez
clair et notamment la discussion qu'on a
au Sénat après la bravème j'ai proposé à
Monsieur Bernal ici ce qui avait dit sur
Twitter qui voulait le faire quand je
dis allez-y et bon il y a pas épané mais
monsieur porte allez-y passez une
journée vous verrez que ce n'est pas du
tout ce que vous avez décrit et je vous
encourage monsieur monsieur me supporte
à savoir que chaque CRS qu'on envoie y
compris à sa suite sont des gens
extrêmement formés et oui c'est une CRS
très mobile parce que nous avons affaire
à des personnes de plus en plus violente
qu'on utilise donc pas en maintien de
l'ordre des coins en violence urbaine et
vous dites Mayotte mais je pense que
vous voyez pas beaucoup nos compatriotes
de Mayotte mais Mayotte il faisait que
les Mahorais sont très heureux le
responsable de les films Mayotte que
j'ai d'ailleurs entendu sur maillot de
première à féliciter le gouvernement et
votre serviteur je tiens la vidéo à la
disposition de la commission des lois en
ampliation gratuite faite par mes soins
si vous voulez me présente pour
féliciter le fait que nous ayons redonné
de la vie de la liberté à Mayotte donc
je vous encourage à rencontrer votre
délégué et les filles Maoré qui lui n'a
pas la même vision que vous de l'action
de la CRS 8 et des gendarmes mobiles
dans le territoire de Mayotte et je
crois que j'ai oui la question sur
Marseille pardon parce que j'arrivais
pas à vous relire bon madame la député
je suis venu je crois cinq fois depuis
un an vous êtes élu à Marseille je crois
pas que je vous ai rencontré
je suis allé pourtant dans beaucoup de
quartiers je suis passe trois jours à
chaque fois vous n'êtes jamais venus me
voir donc je vous ai pas vu c'est
dommage parce qu'on a parlé plein de
choses intéressantes on aurait monsieur
parlant monsieur delogu il vient voilà
il a pas être d'accord mais voilà mais
voilà cinq fois oui je suis venu 5 fois
chez vous vous n'étiez pas là donc
d'abord n'hésitez pas à côté des
Marseillais parce que sinon on va croire
que je me présenter dans votre
circonscription ce qui est évidemment
pas ma volonté je pense que c'est bien
d'aller voir les gens en vrai voilà
je laisse ce plaisir je laisse ce
plaisir au président mouillé voilà si
mais c'est vrai je suis venu cinq fois
vous posez pas de question sur Marseille
madame je suis venu cinq fois vous
n'étiez jamais là pour votre sécurité et
je passe des jours et des jeuniers bon
voilà mais parce qu'elle est ici mais
madame un député c'est quelqu'un qui
s'occupe aussi de territoire surtout
quand il vient donner des leçons ensuite
parce que dire qu'on donne du doliprane
pardon mais c'est très insultant pour
les policiers si tentait que vous
m'aimez pas c'est pas un problème mais
dire que donne du doliprane contre le
trafic de drogue c'est que vous ne
connaissez pas le travail des policiers
des gendarmes à Marseille c'est que
toutes les deux heures il lutte contre
les points de l'île qui risque leur tous
les jours et vous sauriez madame qu'on a
fait non seulement des prises
incontestables à Marseille et que y
compris dans les quartiers je pense à la
paternelle il existe des endroits où il
n'y a plus oui vous habitez à côté mais
il y a plus de point de villes dans cet
endroit précis voilà donc voilà madame
donc je pense que vous n'allez pas
beaucoup dans cette cité en tout cas
vous allez beaucoup moins que j'y suis
allé je vous encourage madame la députée
a plutôt encouragé de travailler les
policiers des gendarmes de pas dire que
quand il risque d'envie tous les jours
il donne du doliprane contre les
trafiquants vous aurez constaté que le
travail de la si c'est ce que vous avez
dit c'est très insultant pour les
policiers gendarmes c'est tout simple
non mais écoutez madame vous avez vos
propos et c'est vrai que de Paris on
voit moins bien le travail que font les
policiers dans les cités de Marseille
c'est tout à fait vrai donc je vous
encourage madame puisque j'y retourne
quotidiennement à partir de cet été j'y
retourne d'ailleurs début août n'hésitez
pas à venir je vous préviendrai un peu
pour que vous puissiez prendre votre vol
entre Paris et votre circonscription
vous avez proposé monsieur le ministre
de rencontrer la CRS suite avec le
député Rudy gos on est allé visiter
l'IGPN et je conseiller à tous les poly
à tous les députés de le faire puisque
on a eu aussi une visite à l'IGPN
Île-de-France où on s'était aperçu la
réalité de ce que vous vous décrivez
c'est à dire de la rigidité en tout cas
la grande rigueur des enquêtes qui sont
conduites à l'égard des policiers qui
sont mis en examen et qui ne passent
effectivement pas un bon moment comme
vous l'avez vu le décrire ce jean
tardier
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais à mon tour m'associer au
remerciements l'endroit des forces de
l'ordre évidemment pour l'engagement qui
était le leur dans le cadre de ces actes
de violence qui n'ont malheureusement
pas épargner le Tarn à Albi a aussi long
et même encore à Castres fort
heureusement ces événements sont
intervenus dans un contexte de hausse
très significative des moyens à
l'endroit des forces de l'ordre dans le
département du Tarn j'en citerai deux
notamment la prise de fonctions récentes
du commissaire de de police de Castres
mais aussi la reconstitution de l'abaque
et ce dont je veux évidemment remercier
néanmoins ces épisodes de violence ont
permis de mettre un peu plus en lumière
les difficultés que rencontrent
certaines circonscriptions sous dotées
en effectif notamment commissariat de
Castres ou trois à quatre postes d'eau
PJ font défaut ainsi que deux policiers
de voies publiques aussi et je vous en
remercie par avance il me semble
nécessaire d'apporter une attention
toute particulière assez territoires qui
s'immisent des actes de violence
répétées vous le savez qui mettent à mal
les effectifs qui montrent aujourd'hui
des signes de factice des signes de
fatigue inquiétants je vous remercie
des écoles de ces violences pour la
répartition sur le territoire est-ce que
vous allez tenir compte quand même de
ces violences en vous disant par exemple
à Montargis 2017 122 policiers 2022 94
hors réserviste et hors personnel
indisponible c'est les chiffres je les
ai et je vous les donnerai si vous
voulez à la fin est-ce que vous allez en
tenir compte dans tous les cas peu
importe les chiffres on fera pas un
combat de chiffres est-ce que vous en
tiendrez compte globalement au-delà de
montargi est-ce que vous allez tenir
compte de cette réalité et puis les
derniers points c'est le refus
idéologique d'un certain nombre de
mairies d'extrême gauche j'en ai une sur
mon territoire à Châlette qui refuse de
mettre des caméras vous avez dit que
c'était un élément important bien
entendu moi j'ai des policiers qui me
disent nous sommes à l'aveugle sur ce
territoire nous ne pouvons pas
intervenir aussi rapidement parce que
nous avons des appels nous ne pouvons
pas voir et donc est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas envisager que l'état d'une manière
ou d'une autre reprennent la main sur
ces territoires qui sont des zones non
endroit et que un certain nombre
refusent de vidéo protégées et de
permettre aux policiers d'intervenir
est-ce que vous pensez aussi augmenter
le FIPD pour donner des moyens
supplémentaires aux collectivités qui
elles pour des questions réelles de
besoin sécuritaire le fond sur le
territoire je vous remercie monsieur
handicaprat
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en juin 2020 l'indignation
quitte à lassassinat de George Floyd et
international en France les alertes sur
le racisme de la police et au sein de la
police se multiplient Christophe
Castaner près des sœurs d’alors
du ministère de l'Intérieur sur l'état
actuel des discriminations dans les
rangs des forces de l'ordre et de
sécurité intérieure vous messieurs
dammanin fraîchement nommé à Bobo vous
avez seulement cherché à cacher les
vérités qui blessent comme un dernier
rapport du Conseil scientifique de la
dilkra sur le racisme et les
discriminations au sein de la police
nationale ce rapport pourtant et tout ce
que jamais d'actualité il appelle un
nommer fait par leur nom s'il fait
d'abord état d'invisibilisation de ces
faits de racisme et discriminations ce
document prouve bien que les
comportement discriminatoires de la
police se multiplient à l'encontre de la
population et qu'il s'acceptue entre les
agents eux-mêmes nous déplorons vous
allez honteusement étouffé que Mediapart
est opté obligé de saisir la CADA pour
pouvoir nous le révéler plutôt qui est
d'essayer d'en parler en tirer les
leçons pourquoi l'avoir gardé dans un
territoire dans un tiroir un service
public de la sûreté peut-être un levier
et doit être un levier pour conserver un
maillage républicain car seule la
confiance permet le consentement à la
règle c'est ce que vous monsieur le
ministre peinez à comprendre mais
camarades ont fait état de comportement
raciste sexistes ou encore je vais te
faire de la police vis-à-vis de la
population combien en absence de vidéo
ou de son passé sous le silence au sein
des institutions combien terrifie
tellement les victimes qu'elle se teste
de peur des représailles de la
hiérarchie l'impunité de certains
factieux du Ratel encore longtemps des
recommandations simples et du rapport
ont été balayés et avec vous ceseries
alternatives des policiers que j'ai
rencontré récemment vous recommande deux
solutions permettent à pouvoir direct de
sanction de les JPN et l'iggn et rendre
leur décision publique auprès des agents
et des victimes ce n'espère pas la mer à
boire mais cela apporterait un regain de
confiance et une exemplarité de ces
institutions
merci monsieur le Président
d'abord permettez-moi au moment de cette
intervention de rendre un hommage sous
la neige aux forces de l'ordre aux
policiers aux gendarmes aux
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont permis que la
République tienne debout dans des
moments
extrêmement périlleux et
particulièrement dangereux je veux
vraiment rendre hommage à nos policiers
je veux les saluer je veux aussi
Monsieur le Ministre saluer la façon
dont vous les avez dirigés l'ordre
républicain a été tenu et c'était
important mais les inquiétudes demeurent
très grandes pour l'avenir vous les
mesurez monsieur le ministre et vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure une une
question qui m'interpelle c'est l'usage
des armes en disant c'est peut-être la
prochaine étape
nous savons que circule beaucoup d'armes
dans ces quartiers nous l'avons vu à
Nice au quartier des Moulins il y a
quelques semaines où en plein jour une
circuler kalachnikov à la main qu'est-ce
que vous permet vous anticipez sur cette
menace est-ce qu'elle est réelle est-ce
qu'elle est
dans le centre de vos analyses quelle
action de renseignement sont conduites
et qu'elle actionne de contrôle sont
autorisées je voudrais ensuite vous
poser une question qui a soulevé
beaucoup de débats dans la presse sur le
rôle des dealers des trafiquants qui
tiennent ces quartiers dans la
régulation qui s'est opérée enfin pour
être clair et pour aller droit au but
est-ce que ce sont les dealers qui ont
remis de l'ordre dans ces quartiers
parce que leur triste commerce leur
sinistre commerce qu'on peut évaluer
environ 10 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires par rapport au trafic de
drogue été mis
était mis en péril par par les
mouvements
canet-il on voit que aujourd'hui les
dealers sont des acteurs sociaux on l'a
vu à Cavaillon où ils installent une
balle une base de loisirs on le voit à
Nice au quartier des liserons où on
parle d'un finan je suis désolé monsieur
Jean-Pierre
merci monsieur le Président mon
intervention va
aller au-delà de du motif de cette
audition mais reste sécuritaire et
surtout d'actualité
hier une cinquantaine de migrants
homme-femme en France ont voulu gagner
la Grande-Bretagne bien sûr c'est
malheureusement fréquent sur la côte de
dopale Meyer c'était en plein jour à
Boulogne-sur-Mer sur la plage et demande
un certain nombre de touristes
d'ailleurs donnant de nombreuses photos
sont maintenant ce matin dans dans la
presse alors on sait bien sûr que ces
passages sont de plus en plus fréquents
mais il cherchait quand même une
certaine discrétion or cette
magnétisation semble inquiétante
pourtant beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
faites mais que faudrait-il faire de
plus pour éviter tous ces passages je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Antoine Léo man
merci monsieur le Président nous sommes
nombreux ici à être issus des quartiers
à être issus de l'immigration et à aimer
notre pays nous ne voulons ni de la
haine des policiers ni de laine des
étrangers nous voulons de l'amour de la
République ces propos monsieur Darmanin
ce sont les vôtres et pour le coup c'est
assez rare mais je les partage
ces propos là doivent vous inviter à
répondre à la question que je vous ai
posé le même jour ce jour là je vous ai
posé une question sur le racisme dans la
police et précisément quand on aime la
République on considère que ce n'est ni
une couleur de peau ni une origine ni
une religion ni quoi que ce soit qui
définit la citoyenneté française c'est
l'attachement à la République
précisément
lutter contre le racisme dans la société
et dans la police c'est le devoir des
républicains et les policiers qui
tiennent des propos racistes salissent
l'uniforme et précisément des tâches un
certain nombre de personnes de la
République parce que que se passe-t-il
quand un policier tient un propos
raciste portant l'uniforme portant le
drapeau tricolore de la République
française il envoie le signal à un de
nos compatriotes qu'il ne serait pas
d'une certaine manière parfaitement et
totalement français lutter contre le
racisme dans la police c'est une demande
de l'ONU et c'est un besoin vital pour
la République parce que sinon on se
détache petit à petit des valeurs de la
République je vous ai rappelé
quelques-uns des propos qui ont été
tenus je continue les auditions avec les
jeunes gens plus j'en fais plus je suis
choqué des propos qu'il me rapporte
quant à un jeune homme se fait traiter
de kebab par exemple par un policier
j'estime que on n'est pas dans l'ordre
républicain quant à policier tient ce
genre de propos ce racisme existe
monsieur Darmanin il contrôle traité et
désormais il faut agir de manière
vigoureuse et efficace sur le sujet que
comptez-vous faire sur ce point
voilà je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier pour pour cette ce moment
important au sein de la commission
dire qu'effectivement nous nous
soutenons les forces de l'ordre et je
dois dire notre non seulement notre
soutien mais notre admiration de ce
qu'ils ont fait au moment des violences
policières hormones des violences
urbaines excusez-moi c'était l'absus non
voulu et non révélateur et je voulais
surtout vous interroger sur le fait
est-ce qu'il ne serait pas tant de
relancer de manière forte la politique
dès qu'elle SPD dci SPD qui sont à la
main des procureurs de la police de
sécurité de la police du quotidien tous
ces outils qui sont à disposition pour
faire le lien dans les territoires entre
justice état et notamment les procureurs
et les élus qui connaissent leur terrain
est-ce que ce serait pas le moment alors
ce n'est pas la seule réponse évidemment
à ces violences urbaines il faudra une
analyse plus profonde mais déjà relancer
fortement cette politique qui peut
permettre sur le terrain de faire un
travail encore plus fort et rassembler
les acteurs qui mènent cette politique
de sécurité
et enfin Monsieur Jean-François Coulomme
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre au lendemain de l'assassinat du
genonnage abattu à bout portant en plein
thorax par un fonctionnaire de police
dans l'exercice de sa fonction le
propagandiste néonazi Jean Messi a lancé
aidé par des médias en total dérive
morales et anti républicaines une
cagnotte en ligne afin de récompenser
l'assassin pour son geste geste létal
salué par tout ce que la droite de notre
pays compte de suprématistes de déodasie
et de racistes cette cagnotte de la
honte a en quelques jours à peine
récolté plus d'un million 600 000 euros
quand la cagnotte du boxeur d’éttinger
pour quelques centaines d'euros avait
immédiatement été suspendu et confisqué
au profit des plaignants monsieur le
ministre nous avons bien quel ordre
votre ministère et les défend mais il
s'agit ici plus que d'une cagnotte c'est
une prime une prime de chasseurs de
primes une prime qui gratifie glorifie
un assassin pour son crime pourriez-vous
prendre à votre compte la bienveillance
des autorités face à un tel procédé qui
s'apparente à un encouragement à
commettre le futur nouveau crime votre
exemplarité en tant que ministre
s'accommodera-t-elle de ce que ces mêmes
sponsors d'assassinat racistes
organisent de prochaines cagnottes à
l'avance pour commanditer et financer
d'autres meurtres par anticipation les
donateurs criminels par procuration en
sont bien sûr capables quelle est la
limite monsieur le ministre à votre
tolérance auriez-vous toléré qu'une
semblable prime soit organisée par des
criminels pour récompenser le meurtre
d'un fonctionnaire de notre pays non
comme nous tous ici assumer réellement
pas enfin Monsieur le Ministre
allez-vous procéder à ce que tout
ministre républicain devrait faire
confisquer cette honteuse cagnotte de la
discorde et de l'incitation au crime et
la reverser à la seule victime et qui
soit encore vivante la famille du jeune
Naël
j'ai donné la parole au ministre je vous
invite
à conserver le calme que vous avez
observé jusqu'à présent j'invite aussi
monsieur Coulomme à la retenue dans les
termes qu'il emploie monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
pense pas avoir
d'abord monsieur le Président si je peux
me permettre j'invite monsieur Léomont
je vais même pas répondu à Monsieur le
mot qui m'est déjà que Darmanin mort
déjà par tweet voilà donc je pense que
c'est pas la peine que je vous réponds
monsieur le mot puisque si vous avez
déjà fait la réponse avant même que j'ai
écrit voilà c'est totalement
désobligeant c'est très pardon de le
dire enfantin et en plus c'est
particulièrement déplacé mais comme je
vous ai vu il y a pas très longtemps sur
les réseaux sociaux faire des
explications très étonnante sur la
marseillais je me suis dit qu'en effet
il y a pas que les policiers qui va être
mieux formés voyez ce député
deuxième non mais je voudrais retirer
tout de suite parce qu'il est
objectivement insultant et il n'est pas
à la hauteur me semble-t-il de votre
intelligence qui je suis sûr et certaine
en cherchant bien je suis sûr qu'on
pourrait trouver un moyen de discuter
mais c'est un point voilà très bien donc
je vous répondrai pas puisque bah non je
vais vous répondrai pas monsieur Léo
parce que vous êtes manifestement
provenant vous êtes manifestement contre
le débat républicain et équilibré et
vous êtes monsieur et Monsieur lemon
manifestement n'est pas tous issu des
quartiers on n'est pas tous issus
d'immigration en tout cas moi je suis
sur le quartier d'immigration et je fais
pas de mobilité je ne sais pas monsieur
le député c'est pas monologue
je n'ai personne pour cette audition je
n'ai personne de ce député monsieur le
député j'ai jamais fait de mobilité
sociologique électorale pour me faire
élire ailleurs que chez moi mais
j'imagine que vous avez toujours habité
et bien sûr dans votre circonscription
pour bien comprendre la difficulté des
quartiers vous m'avez insulté avant même
que je vous ai répondu publiquement
voilà soit soit tout le monde reprend
ses esprits soit on arrête l'addition
c'est clair c'est votre disposition donc
maintenant on répond aux dernières
questions des autres et Monsieur le vent
vous laissez tranquille monsieur le
ministre pour Monsieur Colom bon
j'espère que je prononce bien je pense
que rien ne va dans votre intervention
mais chacun a ses livres propos bien
évidemment et comme vous avez la
gentillesse de pas faire de tweet pour
m'insulter vos joues je me permets de le
faire bien volontiers
d'abord monsieur le député je ne suis
pas certain et heureux ceux qui ont des
certitudes mais que vous soyez procure
la République ou juste l'instruction qui
qualifient
ce qui s'est passé à Nanterre on peut
être choqué je pense que je me suis
exprimé très clairement on peut se poser
de graves questions on peut considérer
que c'est pas ce que l'on souhaite comme
intervention comme loi qui sont votée et
comme action mais évoquer qualifier
d'assassinats racistes ce qu'a fait ce
policier à Nanterre et jugé avant de
juger
et je veux redire ici que si j'ai
considéré que ce policier avait des
indices graves et concordants puisqu'il
est mis en examen et qu'il est en
détention provisoire et que évidemment
j'ai moi-même dit que il ne semble pas
être conforme à des actes de droit et de
déontologie de formation d'intervention
le condamné par avance sans forme de
procès me rappelle des sens de
l'histoire qui ne sont pas d'un terme
démocratique donc je pense que quand on
veut apaiser les situations et regarder
les choses avec on était j'en suis
certain que vous êtes un homme de bien
je crois que on ne peut pas utiliser ses
propos qui sont extrêmement
contraires me semble-t-il au minimum de
l'État droit qu'on attend du reste
par ailleurs vous faites une comparaison
étonnante monsieur le député vous
évoquez l'assassin le policier et le
simple boxeur pour la cagnotte non
c'était quelqu'un qui attaquait des
policiers et tout le monde l'a vu sur
les mêmes vidéos il a sur les ponts de
la scène violentés des pères et des
mères de famille qui faisaient leur
travail et il les a violentés donc vous
pourriez au moins et ça montre peut-être
votre démonstration qui en fait est très
partiel vous n'êtes pas contre les
violences vous êtes manifestement contre
les violences qui sont que d'un camp
vous pourriez au moins qualifier ce
boxeur qui n'est pas comme dans Jack
London quelqu'un qui voudrait juste
travailler pour avoir son steak des gens
qui étaient des agresseurs et ça n'a
rien à voir avec la boxe c'est à tout
avoir avec ta délinquance vous voyez au
moins le qualifier comme tel et puis
troisièmement monsieur le député je vous
ai expliqué deux fois dans l'hémicycle
et je suis désolé de le répéter une
nouvelle fois ce n'est pas le ministre
intérieur qui interdit des cagnottes si
vous voulez voter une loi pour donner
plus de pouvoir vous la France insoumise
à l'intérieur je trouverai que cette
original dans votre idéologie politique
mais je suis pourquoi pas autorisé c'est
la justice et c'est le tribunal final
judiciaire qui a interdit et saisit la
précédente cagnotte je ne suis pas juge
et contrairement à vous j'ai
manifestement pas envie de devenir je
n'ai pas raté ma vocation j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'exprimer comme la promise
sur ce que je pensais de cette cagnotte
à ce titre là vous avez vu que la
justice par ailleurs a été saisie
laisser la justice faire son travail
dans les quatre des lois votés par la
République donc pardon monsieur le
député je ne peux partager vos propos et
je les trouve extrêmement excessif pour
ne pas dire
très contraire au droit sur la
qualification que vous faites vous-même
de ce de cet acte que nous pouvons tous
trouver choquant et je me suis permis de
le dire moi-même et ce qui ne retirer
rien au drame qui a vécu la famille du
jeuneel sur la question de Castres
67 policiers en 2016
76 en 2022 en manque-t-il sans doute il
manque toujours des policiers monsieur
député dans des commissariats bon
j'attends le moment où quelqu'un
m'envoie une lettre pour me dire merci
beaucoup ça a augmenté le 14 et vraiment
il y en a trop on rend des uns aux
autres ce qui manque et vous l'avez dit
ce député monsieur tierlier je connais
votre attachement à la police nationale
et votre circonscription c'est des OPJ
et pourquoi il manque des EPG parce que
je ne peux je le répète une nouvelle
fois dans votre commission je ne peux
envoyer de force des officiers de pêche
judiciaire dans les commissariats je
peux ouvrir des postes et après les gens
ils vont ils vont pas je ne peux pas les
forcer y aller et seul peut ici que je
peux forcer à aller quelque part c'est
lorsqu'ils sortent d'école et grâce à la
loi que vous avez voté et vous aurez
constaté que désormais ils ont réussi
60% des promotions d'ailleurs monsieur
le Président ont réussi le bloc opégi ce
qui montre que ce que nous avons le
premier et première partie de
blocobéisses qui montrent ce que nous
avons imaginé fonctionne et je vais
pouvoir envoyer des premiers blocs OPJ
dans des commissariats mais ça ce sera
les premières promotions que je vais
pouvoir faire maintenant ce que je
pouvais pas faire auparavant
et bravo à Marseille je vais pouvoir
envoyer cette gardiens de la paix
directement à la PJ de Marseille ce que
aucun utilisateur ne pouvait faire avant
grâce à la réforme que nous avons
collectivement voté et puis deuxièmement
il manque structurellement 5000 au PG en
France puisque il devrait avoir 22000 et
qu'on est à peu près 17000
pourquoi il manque des EPG parce que
c'est un concours difficile parce qu'il
faut s'arrêter pour pouvoir travailler
pour passer ce concours et c'est pas
évident quand on est un père et mère de
famille bien évidemment et peut-être
qu'il faut qu'on accompagne davantage
les policiers qui ont envie de passer ce
concours parce que les enquêtes sont par
ailleurs plus complexes avec plus de
paperasseries que ça décourage parfois
les officiers de police judiciaires mais
aussi parce que les hôpitaux ont parfois
fait autre chose que des enquêtes quand
je suis arrivé au mille Center je vous
ai déjà dit que j'avais des EPG ou au
renseignement territoriaux ils font
aucune enquête les OPJ c'est fait pour
faire un travail de police judiciaire et
donc c'est pour ça que la réforme de la
police nationale
ciné si décrié mais qui vous avez vu
avance et avance bien nous permettra de
travailler sur l'ensemble de
l'investigation et je l'espère renforcer
considérablement le rôle stratégie on
leur fait désormais des avancées
profilés ce qui était pas le cas
auparavant aux parents ils choisissez au
PJ et ils avaient moins de chance à
avancer que la moyenne des gardiens de
la paix qui n'était pas au PJ c'était
pas bien il y a une question autour des
horaires et évidemment de la
reconnaissance et puis une question
financière on est passé des années 1500
euros la prime de PJ c'est pas assez
mais ça a beaucoup augmenté vous
continuez que ça augmente donc oui pour
les EPJ viendra le moment où les mises à
l'intérieur en tout cas les prochains
pourront désigner directement en tout
cas beaucoup plus que je ne le fais les
objets dans les commissariats parce
qu'on construit toujours des choses que
les autres inaugures c'est tout à fait
normal et c'est ça c'est ça les vendeurs
de la politique alors à Montargis où je
suis allé monsieur député il y a avant
d'autres élections donc ouais oui mais
il y a beaucoup de villes en France
c'est 36000 communes je sais que je vous
manque mais je viendrai bien volontiers
dans ce beau département du Loiret que
je connais un peu en effet votre ville a
été touchée dans des circonstances
inacceptables et et notamment les
commerçants qui bien sûr voilà et les
effectifs du commissariat de Montargis
étaient pas capable nombre à faire face
à cette violence et moi je veux
remercier leur travail parce qu'il est
quand même été difficile alors je prends
l'exemple de votre commissariat on va
pas faire de la taille de chiffres et
vous en avez quand même donné donc on va
quand même compléter les chiffres tels
que pardon que tous ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui doivent être nombreux à
cette heure tardive monsieur président
ont envie de savoir combien de
temps il y a des 75 en 2017 et à la 68
au 1er septembre 2023 donc il en manque
en effet 7 par rapport à 2017 donc c'est
pas tout à fait des chiffres que vous
avez donné où il en manqué une
quarantaine en voilà donc 7 c'est
beaucoup mais c'est pas 40 non plus
alors je constate que dans à Orléans
dans votre département on est passé de
285 à 306 donc d'abord première chose
Monsieur le Député moi je ne sais pas de
micromanagement il appartient au préfet
ou à la préfète en l'occurrence elle a
des effectifs de police elle les
répartit comme il l'entend dans le
département donc bah consiste que je
redonne et je redonnerai pour Montargis
c'est que il ne doit pas y avoir un
commissariat en France il y a moins de
policiers maintenant qu'il y en a il y a
5 ans donc il y a évidemment un problème
il faut augmenter les effectifs
deuxièmement vous savez que dans les
circonscriptions de police plus petite
comme Montargis il y a un effet
d'attractivité qui est difficile donc là
c'est pareil que pour les EPG moi
j'ouvre des postes ils vont ils vont pas
alors je peux envoyer des sorties
d'école et c'est ce que nous allons
faire dans un syndrome de commissariat
et je vous l'annoncer ici notamment
monarchie mais c'est pas non plus une
solution définitive parce que d'abord
trop de jeunes gardiens de la paix
quelque part c'est jamais bon parce
qu'il faut des brigadiers il faut des
gens qui les encadrent et deuxièmement
après si c'est une punition ils ont
envie de partir donc il y a une question
d'attractivité donc il y a aussi des
connectivités tout n'est pas de la fin
du ministère d'intérieur même si on peut
évidemment améliorer un certain nombre
de choses mais par exemple quand j'étais
mère moi je ferai et c'était difficile
de venir à Tourcoing la gratuité des
cantines pour les enfants ne
fonctionnaires de police ou une solution
de garde quoi qu'il arrive
systématiquement où je m'arrangeais avec
mon office HLM pour trouver des
logements pour les jeunes policiers qui
débutaient donc il y a peut-être aussi
une petite RH à faire collectivement
vous voyez donc on y travaille ensemble
en tout cas j'ai bien conscience qui
manque d'effectifs à Montargis pas la
hauteur de ce que vous évoquez mais sans
doute votre en phase de vouloir
absolument me voir venir dans votre
circonscription vous a poussé à
dramatiser la situation
je veux dire à Monsieur député que j'ai
moi-même publié le rapport viguru qui
est un excellent rapport et vous n'avez
pas tout dit sur la Provigo et c'est
bien dommage parce qu'il est en ligne
sur Internet vous pouvez le consulter au
moment où je parle vous avez évoqué le
racisme de la police contre les gens
d'abord c'est pas le racisme de la
police contre les gens je rappelle que
Monsieur vigourou d'ailleurs écrit noir
semblant qu'il n'y a pas de racisme
systémique dans l'institution policière
d'abord c'est dommage c'est dommage de
pas le dire parce que c'est ce que dit
Monsieur le vigourou
il a dit qu'il y a des policiers ou des
gendarmes parce que c'est un rapport qui
touche d'essence de sécurité qui
commettent parfois des actes racistes
homophobes qui sont absolument
inacceptables bien évidemment ça c'est
le premier point du rapport du groupe
et puis dit un deuxième truc il dit il y
a du racisme parfois entre forces de
l'ordre
non mais je veux pas mettre ma réponse
parce que je si non bon d'accord je vous
réponds plus alors très bien alors pour
ce qui s'est passé pour monsieur cioti
vous avez évoqué la question des armes
il n'y a pas de renseignement
particulière pour savoir si on tire
demain à Bâle réel sur les policiers
avec de la kalachnikov il y a pas de
note de renseignement qui l'évoquent
mais c'est une pression ce que chacun
peut avoir alors il y a peu de fait où
les policiers meurent au gendarmes en
fonction du fait qui soit policier est
visé comme tel saute des opérations
antiterroristes que vous connaissez sauf
quelques rares exceptions qui sont très
choquantes notamment ce policier
d'Avignon vous savez dans l'enquête dira
s'il a été reconnu comme tel ou pas ce
qui est en civil était vu comme une
sorte de bande
concurrente mais enfin en tout cas il y
a manifesté en plus de violences contre
les policiers les gendarmes du fait
d'armes à feu est-ce qu'elles sont
généralisées non est-ce qu'elles sont de
plus en plus importantes les faits
commencent à nous le montrer on
utilise-t-on des des armes de guerre
type kalachnikov entre les policiers
gendarmes à ma connaissance ce n'est pas
le quotidien des forces de l'ordre fort
heureusement parce qu'il existe encore
me semble-t-il une justice et un code
pénal qui évoque le fait que quand on
touche la policier agenda on prend une
peine extrêmement forte
il faut faire attention à cela et redire
monsieur le député que quiconque touche
un policier ou un gendarme se verra
mettre énormément de moyens pour le
retrouver c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour tous les policiers de gens qui ont
été blessés par les émeutes on a mis la
police judiciaire systématiquement vous
avez remarqué qu'on a retrouvé beaucoup
des personnes qui ont attaqué y compris
dans des conditions extrêmement
nébuleuses c'est pas ici et ces
gendarmes et le pire est en sans doute
ce qui s'est passé à Marseille ou deux
policiers ont été modestés et laissés
pour mort sur place on a retrouvé les
auteurs malgré la difficulté donc on met
des moyens de police judiciaires
extrêmement forts on met les meilleures
enquêteurs on met les meilleurs moyens
technologiques pour retrouver ces
auteurs et on les présente à la justice
avec des preuves indiscutable et nous
espérons qu'il fasse 15 20 25 ans 30 ans
de prison parce que toucher un policier
un gendarme c'est c'est permettre
une société de se déliter entièrement et
donc je pense que ce qu'il faut faire
quand on est mis à l'intérieur c'est
mettre énormément de moyens
pour faire des moyens d'enquête un
policier un gendarme est touché et
évidemment ce que je souhaite de
l'autorité judiciaire mais je constate
qu'elle le fait c'est qu'on avait
extrêmement fortement tant qu'on fera ça
je pense qu'il y a une possibilité
monsieur député pour que le scénario
noir du tir à l'arme de guerre contre
les policiers n'existe pas je voudrais
quand même dire que quand on lutte
contre la drogue et contre les points de
l'île on ne vit pas la mer avec une
cuillère mais on empêche les
organisations criminelles de s'organiser
militairement c'est très différent
regardez ce qui se passe en Belgique et
en Pays-Bas où on a laissé faire
malheureusement l'argent et c'est pas le
fait des gouvernements actuels c'est se
précédent de la drogue ils ont pu avoir
de la technologie de la corruption des
armes de guerre et une organisation
paramilitaire quasiment en face de la
police nationale et c'est pour ça qu'on
lutte contre les points de Deal et moi
je veux dire à nos concitoyens que bien
sûr on va pas éradiquer totalement la
drogue mais plus on donnera des coûts
contre les organisations de la drogue
pour retirer de l'argent moins ils
seront forts et donc ils pourront se
payer des corruptions de fonctionnaires
des magistrats des des
enfants qu'on veut kidnapper comme ce
ministre de la justice belge qui a été
vécu ce protection parce qu'il s'est ouh
là où la reine et le roi des Pays-Bas
qui connaissent des menaces contre leur
fille et voilà je pense que c'est très
important donc il faut c'est un
continuum est extrêmement fort je sais
que vous partagez cette opinion contre
ceux qui essayent de toucher la vie d'un
policier ou d'un gendarme
alors sur Boulogne-sur-Mer évidemment
vous avez pris soin monsieur député de
dire que ça n'avait pas de lien avec
l'audition mais je comprends votre
estonnement et votre question vous
m'avez interpellé d'ailleurs ce matin
j'ai demandé au préfet du Pas-de-Calais
au préfet de zone de pouvoir communiquer
ce soir et d'aller à Boulogne-sur-Mer
pour communiquer pour dire qu'évidemment
de prendre en compte cette situation
inacceptable je déploie une unité de
force mobile aujourd'hui à
Boulogne-sur-Mer et sur la Côte d'Opale
pour que cela se reproduise absolument
pas et troisièmement j'y vois ce qu'on
dise des services de renseignement et le
travail que nous faisons une sorte de
nouvelle originalité des passeurs qui
désormais utilise des bateaux taxis si
je comprends bien ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement à Boulogne-sur-Mer pour
pouvoir utiliser la faiblesse des
migrants et pour faire leur triste leur
triste commerce parce qu'on a on
surveille tellement la côte vous le
savez bien parce qu'on a divisé par 15
nombre de personnes qui pouvaient rester
dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais pour
traverser
la Manche que ils utilisent d'autres
moyens et notamment c'est bateau taxi
ce matin nous avons vu ou cette nuit une
originalité voilà que nous devons
combattre donc je vais vous dire
Monsieur le Député de Boulogne-sur-Mer
non seulement que j'adore votre commune
mais vous le savez bien et que par
ailleurs nous allons nous allons mettre
d'y mettre beaucoup de moyens et j'ai
demandé au préfet que j'ai eu tout à
l'heure au téléphone de s'en occuper
personnellement et dans les minutes qui
suivent
sur les selles SPD et sur de manière
générale les réunions que nous avons
avec les élus et sont essentiels et ça
marche très bien quand il y a police
élue mère et justice et notamment les
procureurs de la République le Garde des
Sceaux a pris une instruction
extrêmement importante qui peut-être est
passé sauf à travers les yeux du
d'excellents députés Ribéry sur le fait
que les progrès de la République
devaient désormais assister aux réunions
des maires ce qui n'est jamais arrivé
moi quand j'étais mère dans les
assemblées des mers et de présence
systématiquement je constate que c'est
le cas de plus en plus donc oui il faut
sans doute relancer davantage j'ai
l'impression que c'est fait mais il faut
sans doute le refaire et il y a
comprendre ce qui s'est passé donc la
rétex à faire est compris sur pourquoi
on n'a pas vu arriver et tous les maires
de tous les bords politiques nous ont
dit que voilà ils avaient une vision
extrêmement
étonnée de ce qui s'était passé et que
les médiateurs ne fonctionnaient pas
toujours comme il l'imaginait il pensait
que certains certaines endroits étaient
plus calmes et d'autres plus compliqués
et ça a été révers ce qui s'est passé
donc il faut comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pendant ces émeutes et
objectivement c'est très difficile de le
savoir comme ça
en quelques instants mais vous avez tout
à fait raison les outils de concertation
pour lequel vous avez fait un excellent
rapport me semble-t-il monsieur le
monsieur le député que vous aviez porté
il y a un an maintenant ou des papiers
dedans mais mérite mérite en effet
d'être avantage souligné vous avez vu
qu'on a fait un gros mouvement
préfectoral je le rappellerai à chaque
année des nouveaux préfets que je vois
d'ailleurs demain pour dire à quel point
c'est très important de travailler avec
les préfets et des sous-préfets voilà je
crois monsieur le député monsieur le
Président les réponses que je peux
apporter à vos questions
merci à toutes et tous et donc je lève
cette séance qui était la dernière pour
la session extraordinaire je souhaite
donc à tous de bonnes vacances
parlementaires